Guten Morgen, Thomas.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Du, in Deutschland darf man jetzt ab 20 Uhr auch in der Fußgängerzone kiffen.
Wunderbar, ich setze mich gleich in den Zug.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 488 vom 27. März 2024.
Ja und wir ziehen jetzt mal hier richtig die Sache mal richtig durch, würde ich sagen.
Ich freue mich für euch.
Ja, also tatsächlich wurde jetzt dieses Cannabis-Gesetz beschlossen.
Und man darf jetzt sagen wir mal mit Einschränkungen auch mit ein bisschen Zeug
in der Tasche aufgegriffen werden, ohne jetzt gleich finsterste Bestrafungen zu fürchten.
Das würde ich sagen ist mal ein Fortschritt.
Ja ist es. Da blicke ich neidisch von Österreich drauf. Wir haben sowas nicht.
Wurde diskutiert, wurde wieder verworfen. Das sind wir einfach noch einige Jahre hinten nach.
Ja aber jetzt wenn Deutschland das macht, dann müsst ihr das doch auch machen.
Das dauert aber wirklich noch einige Jahre.
Ja gut, das mag ja sein. Also not all is good.
Also ich meine, man darf zwar jetzt was haben, aber kaufen darf man es irgendwie
immer noch nicht. Also es gibt jetzt sozusagen immer noch keinen richtigen Sale.
Aber man kann jetzt so einen Club gründen. So einen Kifferclub.
Und da darf man dann Mitglied sein. Und wenn man Mitglied ist,
dann darf man sich auch irgendwie, dann darf man so gemeinsam anbauen und sich
irgendwie wie bestimmte Mengen dann auch zukommen lassen.
Also es wird dann sozusagen über so Clubs organisiert. Da müssen wir halt was Passendes gründen.
So ein Chaos-Cannabis-Club oder so.
Ich wollte es gerade sagen, es drängt sich auf, oder? Wie oft wurde dieser Witz schon gemacht?
Tja, das ist, so wird es jetzt wahrscheinlich kommen. Mal gucken.
Also die CSU vor allem hat sich natürlich kräftig dagegen gewehrt.
Also die süddeutschen Staaten, insofern sehe ich auch schon,
dass das für Österreich wahrscheinlich noch eine Weile dauert.
Also es war wirklich so ein Kampf Nord gegen Süd.
Mal was Neues, so. Und der Süden
war natürlich so, ja nee, das kann ja gar nicht sein und Drogen und so.
Und da gab es wirklich ein paar witzige Beiträge auch im Bundestag irgendwie
von so CSU-Leuten, die sich da halt künstlich aufgeregt haben.
Unter anderem war dann aber einer dabei, der es sogar gebracht hat in seinem
Wahlkampf in Bayern, sich im Kontext dieses Wahlkampfs ein eigenes Bier brauen zu lassen.
Also es ist wirklich echt manchmal unglaublich, zu welchen Gedankensprüngen
Politiker fähig sind oder auch nicht fähig sind.
Das heißt, Gendern wird verboten und Cannabis nicht legalisiert.
Ihr könnt Bayern noch abspalten, also wenn wir Bayern und Österreich vereinen.
Ihr würdet die nehmen? Ich weiß nicht, ob das so gut wäre.
Ich fürchte ja.
Oder wäre das dann sozusagen der progressive Norden für Österreich?
Na, so schlimm ist es nicht. Also ich glaube, in Wien hätten wir ein Problem.
Das kann ich mir auch vorstellen. Also München selbst, wie das immer so ist
mit den Großstädten, ist jetzt auch nicht all lost.
Aber du hast ja dann immer noch das Einzugsgebiet und das bleibt natürlich weiterhin problematisch.
In Baden-Württemberg. Naja, also die können, schärfer können sie ganz gut.
Ja, ich meine, es wird ja spannend, wie lange es dauert, bis das in den Konsens
rüberwandelt und sich alle Leute einig sind, dass man das schon immer hätte
machen sollen. Und ich glaube, dann gibt es auch keinen Widerstand mehr daran, oder?
Wenn man das jetzt gut ausgestaltet, dann wird das so alltäglich werden,
dass es hoffentlich gar keine politische Debatte mehr ist in ein paar Jahren.
Und dann vielleicht kann es auch überschwappen in so Länder wie Österreich oder Bayern.
Ja, ich denke auch, man muss jetzt erstmal feststellen nach ein paar Jahren,
dass dadurch immer noch keine brennenden Mülltonnen durch die Straße rollen,
nur weil jetzt irgendwie was legalisiert wird, was ohnehin schon immer hätte legal sein sollen.
Der eigentliche Schritt, den ich jetzt tatsächlich als erstes erwartet hätte,
wäre eher sowas gewesen,
dass man wirklich jetzt auch mal
klar sagt, ja okay wir brauchen jetzt mal eigentlich eine Hanfinitiative.
Weil das Absurde ist ja, dass eigentlich im Rahmen dieser ganzen Verbotsdebatte
auch der Nutzen von Hanf selber komplett zurückgestellt wurde.
Also das hat sich schon gebessert, ich kenne mich da im Einzelnen nicht aus.
Es gibt ja auch Hanfanbaugebiete von jetzt so nicht psychoaktiven Hanf und so,
aber bloß das kann ja noch sehr viel weiter gehen, weil das einfach eine sinnvolle
Pflanze ist, die man für echt viele Sachen benutzen kann.
Und im Rahmen dieser ganzen Befreiung sozusagen von diesen Einschränkungen würde
man natürlich dann auch eine Hanfindustrie weiter befeuern,
weil man einfach unproblematischer das Ganze anbauen kann. Aber naja, mal gucken.
Fortschritte kommen, aber manchmal dauert es einfach. Andererseits ist das für
mich immer wieder ein schönes Beispiel für...
Den Sinusverlauf von so Gesellschaften, in denen mehrere Frequenzen gleichzeitig
stattfinden, weil man hat ja auch oft so diesen fatalistischen Blick,
also viele Leute haben so dieses, früher war alles besser oder jetzt geht alles
den Bach runter, weil man sich eben so eine dieser Frequenzen anschaut,
die gerade so nach unten geht.
Und weil das gerade so das wichtige Thema ist, weil da die Amplitude so stark
ist, dann ist das sozusagen auch prägend für das Bild, aber man sieht dann schnell,
dass es dann etwas niedrigere Frequenzen oder höhere Frequenzen gibt,
die tatsächlich gerade wieder im Auffind sind, wo irgendwelche gesellschaftliche
Wandlungsenergien sich freisetzen, Wo man dann sagt so, ja okay,
aber so ganz nebenbei, das ist jetzt einfach auch akzeptiert,
nachdem es irgendwie auch jahrzehntelang ein Problem war, Schwulenrechte etc.
Also obwohl es immer Sachen gibt, die scheiße werden,
kommen dann viele Dinge einfach mal so nach oben, wo dann die Gesellschaft auch
nicht mehr bereit ist, diesen Widerstand dagegen zu organisieren oder nicht
mehr in der Lage ist, da überhaupt noch einen Widerstand zu organisieren.
Und dann wird es halt einfach wieder akzeptiert.
Insofern kann auch immer wieder mal alles gut werden.
Ja, schöner Tag für Deutschland. Ich freue mich.
So, jetzt gab es in der letzten Diskussion zu unseren Ausführungen eine ganze
Menge Feedback und ein Großteil davon hat sich mit dem Anzeigenhauptmeister
beschäftigt, dem Phänomen.
Und naja, also
ich finde das
ist alles eine sehr schwierige und
leider auch sehr polarisierende und polarisierte Diskussion und manche oder
viele haben so in ihren Kommentaren dann auch schnell so eine Dichotomie aufgemacht mit,
Also Radfahrer versus Autofahrer, was ja auch gerade so eine aktuelle Diskussion ist.
Also zumindest in Deutschland merke ich, dass das einfach da so heiß diskutiert wird.
So ja, Radfahrer versus Autofahrer und Autofahrer böse und Radfahrer gut.
Und das ist irgendwie alles so schwarz-weiß an der Stelle.
Und als Mutterradfahrer fühlst du dich dem Ganzen überlegen und schwebst darüber bei den Gruppen.
Ja und als Fußgänger frage ich mich dann halt auch so, was ist jetzt mit uns?
Also da stecken natürlich viele Sachen drin, aber ich muss auch sagen,
die Debatte, die ich so mit Linus geführt habe, fühlten wir uns dann halt teilweise
auch so ein bisschen missverstanden.
Weil in der ganzen Debatte um diesen Anzeigenhauptmeister ging es uns eigentlich
weniger um diese konkrete Verkehrsfrage, sondern eher so diese Frage von,
was passiert eigentlich,
wenn jetzt jemand anfängt, solche Gesetze so aktiv anzuwenden.
Ja, also sozusagen, also nicht aktiv anzuwenden, sondern so übermäßig zu berichten,
das ist ja, er wendet ja das Gesetz in dem Sinne nicht an, er ist ja kein Gericht,
sondern er ist ja quasi nur Tippgeber für die Behörden,
ob man nicht mal was verfolgen könnte und tut das dann aber obsessiv und das
eben, ja, ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste, würde ich mal sagen.
Und meine These war ja, dass die Wirkungen von Gesetzen sich ändern,
wenn sie immer angewendet werden.
Dass es dann einfach einen Unterschied macht und das in gewisser Hinsicht in
der Gesetzgebung auch eingepreist ist, dass das eben nicht funktioniert.
Immer stattfindet. Also wenn nicht explizit, dann implizit in gewisser Hinsicht.
Also man hätte vielleicht, wüsste man von einem Gesetz, dass es dann so massiv
permanent zum Einsatz kommt, dann wäre es vielleicht auch anders entworfen worden.
Das ist so ein bisschen meine Grundthese. Und die Angst, die ich so ein bisschen
sehe hier, ist halt, dass wir eben durch Technik, in dem Fall halt Smartphones, Vernetzung etc.
Jetzt quasi in so eine Vollzeitüberwachung durch so Bürgerwehren kommen.
Weil einfach Leute auf bestimmte Aspekte des Rechtssystems jetzt voll abfahren,
beziehungsweise das auch so als Werkzeug sehen.
Naja, also gerade im Hinblick auf Radfahrer versus Autofahrer,
gab es dann halt so Zitate, also gab es so Meldungen in den Kommentaren, so ja,
Gefährder müssten wieder in die STVO gezwungen werden.
Ja, oder wer das Einhalten der STVO als Gängelung bezeichnet ist aus der Diskussion
raus, das ist mir ehrlich gesagt alles ein bisschen zu hart und auch eben zu
polarisierend, weil man kann halt auch beides sein.
Also ich bin halt Radfahrer und Autofahrer und Fußgänger in einem und ich wechsle
jetzt nicht irgendwie fließend von Retter der Welt zu Mörder,
nur weil ich jetzt gerade mal mein Transportmittel wechsle.
Und interessant finde ich halt auch, dass da so eine Privilegiendiskussion auch
draus gemacht wird weil ich meine,
Schwächere gibt es immer und wenn man als Radfahrer unterwegs ist dann hast
du halt auch Schwächere und unter anderem habe ich ja dieses Beispiel gebracht,
dass ich das eben oft sehe das ist halt einfach so.
Radfahrer, sagen wir mal rote Ampeln zum Beispiel,
Sehr viel mehr in Frage stellen.
Also die Sinnhaftigkeit sozusagen mehr in Frage stellen.
Und ich finde das auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so schlimm, weil man kann ja
sowieso und sollte eigentlich auch immer Sinnhaftigkeit von Regeln in Frage stellen.
Und wenn man halt irgendwie an so einer roten Ampel steht, die da zwar jetzt steht,
aber wo einfach sehr offensichtlich ist, dass wenn ich da jetzt weiterfahre, nichts passieren kann,
weil einfach die Situation so ist, dann habe ich zwar im Prinzip einen Regelverstoß
begangen, wenn ich dann darüber fahre, aber die Frage ist halt,
ist die Welt jetzt in diesem Moment schlechter geworden,
weil ich mich über eine Regel hinweggesetzt habe, die in dem Moment einfach
nichts wirklich verhindert.
Oder eben nicht.
Aber vor allem auch eine Regel, die die Person, die gerade den Regelverstoß
begeht, mehr gefährdet als andere.
Wenn da jetzt gerade nicht gegenüber von dir am Zebrastreifen jemand drüber
geht, dann ist die Eigengefährdung, dass dich ein Auto von der Seite erwischt, um einiges höher.
Ich glaube schon, dass es für Autos super wichtig ist, dass sich da alle dran
halten, auch wenn es eine unnötige Situation ist, wo keiner rundherum ist und
man einfach drüber fahren könnte.
Aber, ja, ich meine, wir haben in Wien das wirklich so als Schmäh,
dass es wirklich total verpönt ist, das ist auch der erste Trick an alle Touristen,
ja nicht auf dem Radweg gehen, weil die Radfahrer da sehr penibel darauf achten,
dass ihnen dieser Platz nicht genommen wird.
Das ist so die erste Regel, die man in Wien lernt.
Und als Radfahrer kann ich das auch bestätigen, weil du bist natürlich dann
auch in dieser Situation auf einmal konfrontiert mit schwächeren Verkehrsteilnehmern
und du musst halt anders fahren, wenn du dich nicht darauf verlassen kannst,
dass dann nur andere Radfahrer oder eben vielleicht diese dummen Rollerfahrer
mit dir auf diesem Fahrstreifen sind.
Genau, also es ist auch alles sehr kontextabhängig und ich glaube,
dass man in allen Bereichen Verhalten findet,
was diskussionswürdig ist und dass Radfahrer dann wiederum auch schnell zum
Stärkeren werden und wenn sie dann mit Fußgängern interagieren müssen auch schnell
zum Problem werden können, ist halt genauso klar.
Deswegen mag ich eben diese einfachen gut-böse Sachen nicht und es ist auch
nicht so, dass jetzt irgendwie von jedem Autofahrer per se eine Gefahr ausgeht.
Potenziell ja, klar, weil schweres Gerät ist natürlich immer gefährlicher als leichtes Gerät.
Aber dass jetzt die Motivation automatisch auch bei allen, die Autofahren so
wäre, ist halt meiner Meinung nach auch Quatsch.
Und das Hauptproblem ist halt so ein bisschen, dass einfach Verkehr an sich
einfach natürlich gefährlich ist, aber wir wollen ja auch Verkehr haben und
wir haben ja auch Vorteile von Verkehr, sonst könnte man ja auf Verkehr komplett verzichten.
Aber wie gesagt, es ist halt am Ende diese Umsetzung und man muss sich halt
auch immer fragen, ist in dem jeweiligen Moment,
liegt wirklich ein Problem vor, was gelöst werden muss oder nicht und da gab
es ja dann in diesem Spiegel TV Ding, was weiß ich, die Situation,
da hat dann halt jemand vor seiner Dönerbude irgendwie mit seinem Auto gehalten
und der Dönerbesitzer hat da halt irgendwie Sachen eingeladen. eingeladen.
So und da wo er stand, da war dann halt irgendein Verkehrsschild.
Niemand da, verstehst du, also eine vollkommen unproblematische Situation,
aber weil es gibt ja hier Regel XYZ, musste dann eben gleich fotografiert und angeschwärzt werden.
Also eine ähnliche Situation mit so kurzzeitigen Parken.
Also die Motivation dieses Anzeigenhauptmeisters, wie er sich ja selber nennt, das ist halt so.
Die Durchsetzung einer Ordnung, so einer Richtigkeit oder so ein Vollzugsdefizit,
was dann jetzt behoben werden muss,
aber dann in dem Moment eher dann durch so einen Vollzugsüberschuss ersetzt wird.
Und das fand ich halt problematisch, genauso auch wie so seine Anmaßung so einer
polizeiähnlichen Wirkmacht,
was sich ja auch dadurch zeigt, dass er ja dann tatsächlich mit diesem,
wie er selber sagt, spaßhaften Polizeischild irgendwie an seinem Fahrradkorb
durch die Gegend lauscht.
Er hat dann sozusagen nur so den unteren Strich des E entfernt,
dass es dann aussieht wie ein F und dann sei es ja sozusagen nicht mehr das,
aber es ist halt klar, dass er diese Wirkung in gewisser Hinsicht auch erzielen möchte.
Auch durch diese merkwürdige Uniformität mit seinem Sicherheitsklamotten,
die er dann irgendwie trägt.
Naja, also dieses Entscheiden, wann Regeln sinnvoll sind, finde ich ist ein wichtiges Regulativ.
Das müssen wir uns einfach auch erhalten.
Und weil wenn wir immer Gesetzestexte, ich meine wir diskutieren ja Regeln oft
genug im Sinne von das was dabei rausgekommen ist, ist ein Kompromiss,
das was dabei rausgekommen ist, das ist nicht richtig durchdacht worden.
Aber dann im nächsten Moment, das was dann dabei rausgekommen ist sozusagen
als ein absolutes Allheilmittel und die unanfechtbare Wahrheit zu betrachten,
ist dann natürlich nochmal extra problematisch.
Damit will ich jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass jetzt alle Verkehrsregeln scheiße
sind, mit Sicherheit nicht, aber eben nicht zwangsläufig immer alle auch in
allen Situationen und das ist natürlich so ein Ding.
Und wir haben ja dann auch schon gesehen, was passieren kann.
Wenn solche Regeln auf einmal angewendet werden in einer Art und Weise,
wie es vielleicht nicht gedacht ist.
Also denk mal an Abmahnanwälte, die also jetzt im Internet dann maßenhaft irgendwelche
Abmahnungen verschicken, weil steht ja im Gesetz, muss ja dann recht sein,
kann man erstmal nichts gegen machen.
Machen, aber war halt so nicht gedacht, aber wird dann eben entsprechend missbraucht
und dann ist es halt schon ganz sinnvoll,
wenn man da mal so ein bisschen den Kopf einschaltet, weil nach wie vor meiner
Meinung nach sind die Ziele von Regeln und Gesetzen halt irgendwie ein friedliches
Miteinander zu organisieren und,
Und vor allem erstmal das, sodass man erstmal normal miteinander umgehen kann. Naja.
Vor allem, ich denke mal so, man sollte nicht einen Kulturkampf in so Rechtsgebiete hineintragen.
Das hat man ja auch bei den Klimaklebern
gesehen, dass die Regeln sehr unterschiedlich angewendet werden.
Ich glaube, diese tolle Aktion nach den Bauernprotesten, wo die Jugendlichen
sich dann hingestellt haben mit Spielzeugtraktor und dem Schild,
wir dürfen das, wir haben Traktor dabei.
Also ich glaube schon, dass genau deshalb ja auch dieses Thema so Wellen schlägt,
weil es resoniert mit Leuten.
Das ist bei Verkehr oft so, weil hier haben wir einen sehr verrechtlichten Bereich, der den Zweck hat,
sehr berechtigterweise Unfälle zu verhindern, Leben zu retten und für geordnete
Verhältnisse zu sorgen.
Und deswegen ist es ja auch irgendwie was, dass man dann vielleicht eher bei
der Polizei sieht, die auch nicht immer richtig handelt.
Also da kennt jeder, glaube ich,
auch Geschichten, wo Regeln ungerechtfertigterweise angewendet werden.
Und dieser junge Mann, der sich da als Polizeihauptmeister befindet.
Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Anzeigenhauptmeister, Entschuldigung. Jetzt habe ich ihm Unrecht getan.
Und ich befürchte halt einfach,
dass das eben so wie in der Analogie zum Drachenlord, die ihr gezogen habt,
halt in einen Nerv sticht und deswegen nicht die besten Aspekte der Menschheit
nach außen kehrt, wenn man sich den Diskurs so anschaut.
Also ich hoffe, dass dem jetzt nichts passiert, dass der irgendwie ja für sein
Hobby jetzt nicht gemärtyrert wird.
Aber es ist schon auch irgendwie so eine Debatte, wieso regt dieses Thema so
auf, wieso gehen die Gemüter da so hoch.
Das lässt mich als Anthropologe ein bisschen zweifelnd zurück.
Genau, ich meine jetzt sammelt er irgendwie für eine Bahncard 100 und nochmal
ein bisschen Geld, damit er jetzt quer durch Deutschland fahren kann,
um überall alle anzeigen zu können und da frage ich mich halt wirklich,
was soll das halt groß bringen.
Ich meine, wenn man jetzt mal schaut, wo man so ein Verhalten auch noch an den Tag legen kann,
also haben wir auch teilweise schon erwähnt, was weiß ich hier so Straßenlandnutzung,
kannst du natürlich jetzt losgehen und jedes Restaurant anzeigen,
wo der Tisch auf der Straße zehn Zentimeter weiter in den Bürgersteig reinragt,
als es jetzt irgendwie mit der Gemeinde in dem Moment ausgemacht ist.
Ja klar, das kann man irgendwie korrigieren, aber dann sozusagen rumzugehen,
alle anzuzeigen oder das weiß ich hier in Berlin auch immer wieder so ein Thema,
so Sonntagsöffnung von irgendwelchen Spätis oder so oder Leinenpflicht für Hunde,
also du kannst alle möglichen Regularien und Ordnungen rauskramen und wirst
immer jemanden finden, der dagegen verstößt.
Die Frage ist halt nur, was bringt das?
Und denk mal so im Hinblick auf Sperrzeiten für Bars oder Clubs oder generell Ruhestörung.
Damit kannst du natürlich dein Umfeld auch auf eine Art und Weise terrorisieren, bis es halt,
einfach, bis einfach gar keiner mehr Spaß hat. Und das ist irgendwie alles problematisch.
Ich will trotzdem noch mal so ein paar Kommentare auch noch mal aus dem Blog rausnehmen.
Moos schreibt, zum Thema Anzeigenhauptmeister muss ich mich ja auch noch mal äußern.
Ich zeige ebenfalls relativ häufig Falschparker an und kann das erklären, warum.
Ich kann erklären, warum und was dabei meine Perspektive ist.
Zum einen zeige ich nicht alles an, sondern nur, was mich nervt.
Das sind vor allen Dingen Gehwegparker und Radwegparker. Mir geht es um den
Schutz der schwächeren Verkehrsteilnehmerinnen.
In diesem Sinne mache ich es genauso, wie es Linus gefallen sollte.
Das Problem ist, dass die Gesetze an dieser Stelle das Einzige sind,
was Menschen vor Autos schützt.
Damit diese Gesetze das können, muss die aber auch irgendwer durchsetzen.
Die Polizei interessiert es für gewöhnlich nicht.
Vielerorts die lokalen Ordnungsämter auch zu wenig. Eure Passage zu den roten
Ampeln mag unterhaltsam sein, hat aber einen wahren Kern, den auch schon Michael
Colville Anderson in seinem Buch Copenhagenize herausgearbeitet hat.
Solange die Städte nur auf das Auto zugeschnitten sind, sind sie es auch,
die sich an alle Regeln zu halten haben.
Die anderen sind schon damit beschäftigt, sich durch diese Zumutung an Infrastruktur zurechtzufinden.
Die Regeln sind nicht für sie gemacht, sie sind gegen sie gerichtet.
Dann liegt es in der Natur der Sache, dass sie sich den Regeln auch widersetzen.
Mich freut am Ende der Gedanke, dass alle Autofahrer damit rechnen dürfen,
dass Menschen auf Fahrrädern Kameras benutzen müssen, um ihr Treiben zu dokumentieren.
Wenn du mich dazu zwingst anzuhalten, hast du dir das Foto zu deinem Regelverstoß verdient.
Ja, also klar, also wenn,
ein Vorfall passiert, wo wirklich aktiv ein Problem entstanden ist,
dann bin ich halt auch voll dabei andererseits, was hier auch ganz gut rauskommt ist.
In dieser Debatte ist das Problem vor allem einfach das Design unserer Städte.
Also es ist halt einfach, der Verkehr selber muss umgebaut werden und man muss nicht weit gucken.
Kopenhagen heißt ja auch im Prinzip mal Kopenhagen als Vorbild zu nehmen.
Man kann natürlich genauso gut auf die Niederlande schauen,
wo eben einfach der Verkehr sich dadurch regelt, dass eben auch die Städte anders
gebaut werden und das ist meiner Meinung nach das,
worauf man eben auch sich konzentrieren müsste, weil diese ganzen Konflikte
würden oft halt gar nicht entstehen, wenn sie denn überhaupt gar nicht technisch möglich sind.
Also indem man halt einfach das Design anders macht.
Weil ich meine, alles mit Strafen zu belegen, alles zu bestrafen und nur mit
Strafen alles lenken zu wollen, ist meiner Meinung nach ein Irrweg.
Gut, dann ein Tim mit ganz vielen M's sagt.
Könnte man faire und möglichst sachliche Kriterien dafür aufstellen.
Zum Beispiel könnte man ausschließlich Fälle, in denen eine Behinderung,
eine Gefährdung oder ein Sach- oder Personenschaden entsteht, ahnden.
Das hätte vielleicht für Tim interessante Folgen. Zum Beispiel die Normalisierung
des Überfahrens roter Ampeln, insbesondere von Radfahrern, die dabei aufgrund
ihrer geringen kinetischen Energie nur eine geringe Fahrer ausstrahlen.
Das ist aber bestimmt nicht vom Gesetzgeber gewollt, sonst stünde es anders geschrieben.
Mit der biometrischen Massenüberwachung und der vollautomatischen Echtzeitahndung
aller Ordnungswidrigkeiten ergeben sich desweiteren neue Potenziale für die
Entstehung von Bürgerbewegungen,
die die Festschreibung neuer Grundrechte, zum Beispiel das Recht auf Falschparken
oder das allgemeine Recht auf schadensfreien Rechtsbruch fordern.
Naja, daraufhin Titus von Unhold, das heißt aber, dass nur ein willkürlich oder
zufällig, achso er bezieht sich auf den Satz, das heißt aber,
dass nur ein willkürlich oder zufällig ausgewählter Anteil der Verstöße geahndet werden soll.
Weil ich denke nicht, dass das diese Willkür beabsichtigt oder erwünscht ist.
Und dazu meint er, doch ist es, der Gesetzgeber hat sogar bestimmt,
dass es ein Opportunitätsprinzip gibt und bei pflichtgemäßen Ermessen der Rahmen
von Nichtstun über Ermahnen bis zu Sanktionen reichen kann.
Ordnungswidrigkeiten sind Handlungen gegen die allgemeine Ordnung, keine Straftaten.
Genau, und das ist, glaube ich, ein wichtiger Punkt, dass eben bei Ordnungswidrigkeiten,
und darüber reden wir eigentlich hier die ganze Zeit, im Kontext des Anzeigenhauptmeisters,
es eben sehr wohl genau diese Abstufung auch gibt, nämlich eben dieses Opportunitätsprinzip.
Und die dann halt sagt, okay, es kann hier,
was weiß ich, es kann eine Geringfügigkeit eines Verstoßes vorliegen,
es kann auch ein öffentliches Interesse geben und auch das Täterverhalten nach
der Tat kann eine Rolle spielen in der Bewertung.
Also es ist nicht alles schwarz-weiß.
So in dem Zusammenhang sind dann auch nochmal verschiedene Links gepostet worden.
Es gab nämlich dann tatsächlich bei Frag den Staat eine Nachfrage in der Gemeinde Gräfenheinichen.
Das ist der Ort, wo der Anzeigenhauptmeister primär unterwegs ist.
Jetzt wo er aber seine Bahncard 100 bekommt, demnächst auch noch in anderen
Gemeinden. Ja, Deutschlandticket hat ihm da auch schon sehr geholfen.
Da wurde nämlich mal nachgefragt, wie viele privat eingereichte Anzeigen denn
eigentlich tatsächlich bearbeitet wurden.
Und für 2022, wie gesagt jetzt nur in der Gemeinde Gräfenhainichen,
wo er ja wild unterwegs war, gab es 29 Anzeigen, eingeleitete Verfahren, daraufhin null.
In 2023, wo er dann so richtig aktiv wurde, Anzeigen durch private Personen
889, eingeleitete Verfahren 22.
Also nur bei 22 von 889 wurde überhaupt ein Verfahren eingeleitet.
Warum wissen wir jetzt nicht.
Und von diesen eingeleiteten Verfahren endeten mit Einstellungen nach entsprechender Prüfung 7,
also 7 von 22 wurden eingestellt, mündliche Verwarnung nach geprüfter Einlassung 5, also 5 von diesen 22,
da wurde eine mündliche Verwarnung ausgesprochen.
Und ein Verwarngeld in 10 der Fälle.
Also 10 von fast 900 ist jetzt keine besonders hohe Quote.
Wow.
Es gab dann auch ein paar andere Beispiele, Worms, da war dann die Zahl von
Privatanzeigen zu, wie viele da eine Folge gehabt haben, ein bisschen höher,
aber das ist natürlich jetzt auch alles nur so Ausrisse.
Da zeigt sich aber in gewisser Hinsicht mehrere Sachen. Auf der einen Seite
dürfen wir natürlich in der öffentlichen Verwaltung gar nicht die Kapazität
haben, jetzt solchen massenhaften Anzeigenkram zu bearbeiten und vielleicht ist das auch ganz gut so.
Und andererseits ja, nicht alles was sozusagen angeschwärzt wird ist dann am
Ende in der Bewertung auch wirklich ein solcher Fall,
Ach ja, also es ist eine schwierige Diskussion aber ich muss an der Stelle auch
nochmal die Principia Discordia zitieren die,
sich hier auch interessant zu äußert, wie ich finde Nämlich mit einer Feststellung dass,
die Gesellschaften oft ein bisschen die falsche Ausrichtung haben.
Weißt du, was die iristische Delusion ist, Thomas?
Nein.
Die iristische Delusion, also nach Iris, der Göttin des Chaos,
des Streits und so weiter, der Auseinandersetzung, die iristische Delusion ist
sozusagen die Vorstellung, dass alles, was Chaos ist, ist gut.
Also nur wenn sich alles in totaler Auflösung und regelfrei bewegt,
sodass das irgendwie ein idealer Zustand ist.
Dementsprechend gibt es auch noch die aneristische Delusion,
die wiederum sagt, dass nur das, was in totaler Ordnung ist und vollkommen in
Regeln festgehalten ist, dass das irgendwie gut ist.
Und naja, das kann man halt auch anders sehen.
Sein, destruktive Ordnung als ein unerwünschtes Äquivalent zur destruktiven Unordnung abzulehnen.
Der Fluch des Graugesichts umfasste die Teilung des Lebens in Ordnung,
Unordnung als die wesentliche positive negative Polarität,
anstatt eine Grundlage mit Kreativität und Destruktivität als das wesentliche
positive negative Element zu bauen.
Dadurch hat er den Menschen dazu gebracht, die destruktiven Aspekte der Ordnung
zu erdulden und hat den Menschen daran gehindert, effektiv an der kreativen
Nutzung der Unordnung teilzunehmen.
Die Zivilisation spiegelt diese unglückliche Teilung wieder.
Mit anderen Worten, wir müssen uns darauf konzentrieren, die kreativen Aspekte
von Ordnung und Unordnung zu begrüßen und die destruktiven Elemente außen vor zu halten.
So, das habe ich jetzt Kraftkraft meines Amtes als Papst,
habe ich das jetzt mal hier ausgesprochen und in diesem Zusammenhang kann ich
auch noch kurz alle Hörerinnen und Hörer dieses Podcast selbst zum Papst oder zur Päpstin ernennen.
Das darf ich nämlich als diskordischer Papst, darf ich auch alle anderen zu
Päpsten ernennen und das ist auch ganz praktisch, weil als Papst, wie du weißt,
ist man ja weitgehend geschützt vor Geheimdiensten und anderen Bösewichtern
und das kann sich nur als hilfreich herausstellen.
Das ist sehr positiv, gerade für unsere Hörerinnenschaft. Ich finde es schön,
dass wir vom Anzeigenhauptmeister zum Diskordialismus gekommen sind.
Und in Wirklichkeit ist aber auch gerade die Statistik so, das,
was du vorher erzählt hast, von dem ich am meisten noch hängen bleibe,
weil das zeigt ja auch, wir haben hier eine Kulturkampfdebatte und nicht wirklich
etwas, wo es um die konkreten Regeln geht.
Also ich meine, das ist ein Hobby, das in der Öffentlichkeit geführt und der
sehr stark debattiert wird, aber jetzt an rechtlichen Konsequenzen dürfte das
verschwindend gering sein.
Ja, ich meine, ich hätte es auch spannend gefunden,
da vielleicht nochmal die Zahlen rauszusuchen für so Städte wie Kopenhagen oder
Paris, wo die Autos zurückgedrängt wurden und wo du einfach schöne Trennung
hast und diese Radhighways, wo man sich nicht mehr in die Quere kommt.
Und meine Hoffnung wäre, dass auch dort die Anzeigen einfach sehr stark runtergehen.
Also wie du vorher gesagt hast, das ist das Design unserer Städte,
über das wir hier stolpern.
Und dieser Trickster-Charakter des Anzeigenhauptmeisters stupst uns da eigentlich
nur mit der Nase auf das, was das mit uns tut. Und das ist nicht schön.
Ja, genau.
Gut, wechseln wir das Thema. Es gab noch Feedback, jetzt wird es kürzer, zu den Normen.
Also es ging um diese Beschlusslage oder diese gerichtliche EuGH-Entscheidung,
dass Normen, die in Gesetzen stehen, dann auch im öffentlichen Zugriff sein müssen.
Und wir haben uns ein bisschen über Normen unterhalten und wie man das so halten sollte.
Per Mail meldete sich dann Christian bei uns.
Ihr hattet im Beitrag Europäische Normen und Bezahlschrank über die freie Veröffentlichung
von Normen, die Bestandteil von EU-Rechtsvorschriften sind gesprochen.
Dazu ein kleiner Lifehack. Es gibt sogenannte Normenauslegestellen mit einem
Link dabei, wo Auslegestellen aufgelistet sind.
Dort kann man so ziemlich alle internationalen Normen ISO, IEC, aber auch DIN, VDE etc.
Einsehen. In Berlin geht das zum Beispiel in der Bibliothek der TU.
An den dortigen Computerarbeitsplätzen kann man die Normen aus der Normendatenbank
Perinorm als PDF herunterladen.
Ich habe jetzt nicht auf die Schnelle geprüft, ob und zu welchen Zwecken man
sich die PDF zusenden oder auf dem USB-Stick speichern oder vor Ort ausdrucken
darf. Dies wird aber zumindest technisch nicht verhindert.
Vielleicht hilft das jemandem, der oder die gerne mal etwas in den Normen recherchieren
möchte. Sehr hilfreicher Hinweis.
Dann schreibt Jan P. noch.
Erstmal Überlegungen angestellt werden, ob der eigene Etat die Anschaffung stemmen
kann oder ob es da wert ist.
Im Endeffekt läuft alles darauf hinaus, dass man bei Bekannten in den anderen
Ämtern nachfragt, ob diese Normen zufällig da haben und man erhält die Informationen
über die Telefonleitung.
Generell finde ich es auch oft schwierig, fixe Normen in ein Gesetz zu schreiben.
Zum Beispiel enthält die Technische Anleitung zum Schutz gegen Lärm die TA Lärm
von 1998 einen Verweis auf die VDI 2714,
die jedoch mittlerweile weil er zurückgezogen wurde und der Regelsetzer des
Normeninstituts empfiehlt die Nutzung der DIN 9613.
Jetzt muss die Verwaltung dennoch die alte Norm anwenden, da diese im Regelwerk
festgeschrieben wurde.
Alles nicht so einfach mit den Normen.
Ja, ja, also diesen Link geben wir auf jeden Fall nochmal rein.
Das ist von Beuth, von dem Verlag, der die Normen herausgibt.
Ja klar, man kann da wahrscheinlich in Bibliotheken sich eine Kopie ziehen,
aber ich glaube 2024 sollten wir schon, kann man da nicht mal sowas wie Pirate
Bay machen und einfach das alles an Wissen befreien?
Ich meine, das ist ja in der Wissenschaft dann sicher auch dasselbe Problem.
Ja, also es kam auch oft noch der Hinweis, Kommentaren, dass das natürlich mit
der Finanzierung alles nicht so einfach ist, weil klar, da arbeiten natürlich
auch viele Leute daran, dass es diese Normen gibt und dass sie ordentlich aufbereitet
sind und dass sie auch stimmen und all das ist ja auch richtig.
Und vielleicht muss jetzt auch nicht die Antwort unbedingt sein,
dass man von dem aktuellen Regime komplett in ein alles muss frei immer jederzeit sein,
weil die Argumentation ja schon die ist, dass es ja auch was weiß ich für Unternehmen
dann sinnvoll ist, solche Normen zu beziehen.
Und die ja wirtschaftlich arbeiten, können sie daran auch irgendwie investieren,
weil sie ja dann auch von der Arbeit der Normungsinstitute profitieren.
Das mag alles sein.
Hier ging es aber jetzt in der Debatte darum, was ist, wenn das sozusagen Gesetz wird.
Und dann, Gesetze müssen halt in irgendeiner Form anwendbar und überprüfbar sein.
Und wenn das dann an Geld gebunden ist, weiß ich auch nicht so richtig, ob das so sinnvoll ist.
Das betrifft ja dann aber auch wirklich nur einen Teil und wahrscheinlich auch
einen sehr kleinen Teil der Normen und ich denke, da können wir schon mal auf diesen Weg kommen,
dass das dann eben durch so ein Gesetz dann eben auch entsprechend einfacher
zu beziehen ist, insbesondere durch Ämter.
Also das, weil an der Stelle zahlt es ja dann doch wieder der Staat,
dann kann man also auch gleich in eine direkte Finanzierung übergehen.
Es erinnert mich so ein bisschen an die Wissenschaftsverlage,
die die Arbeit von Wissenschaftlerinnen, die oft steuergeldfinanziert ist,
dann in Journals hinter Bezahlschranke publizieren, für das die Uni dann wieder
zahlen muss, damit sie überhaupt den Diskurs verfolgen kann.
Das ist so ein bisschen diese selbe kaputte Form von Geschäftsmodell,
die auf Informationsverknappung basiert und ja, da müsste man sich was Besseres überlegen.
So letzter Teil vom Feedback, da ging es dann um die Abhöraffäre mit dem Bundeswehr-Talk
über die Taurus-Situation.
Also wo Mitglieder der Bundeswehr sich in so eine WebEx-Konferenz nicht per
Internet eingewählt haben,
sondern per Telefon und dann von Russen abgehört wurden und die Russen das dann veröffentlicht haben.
Dazu schreibt Bina, zu eurer Verwunderung, um nicht zu sagen eurem Entsetzen,
was da bei der Bundeswehr passiert ist, das riesige Problem ist doch,
dass da einfach nicht so viel funktioniert, dass ich denen noch nicht mal den
riesigen Vorwurf mache.
Die wollten wahrscheinlich einfach dieses Meeting durchziehen und weil Dinge
nicht funktioniert haben, wurde dann halt das Handy genommen.
Warum überhaupt dieses depperte System?
Wohl derselbe doofe Grund, warum alle Schulen mit Teams arbeiten.
Es funktioniert halt einfach so gut wie mit jedem System.
Ja, das war bestimmt die Motivation, aber ich glaube es gibt schon noch einen
Unterschied zwischen der Schule und Teams,
was die Schutzbedürftigkeit der Informationen betrifft und so einer internationalen
sicherheitspolitischen Debatte. Debatte.
Rico schreibt, zur Bundeswehr und WebEx ausgeschlossen, dass unsere Cyber-Werder
erfolgreich einen schönen Honeypot aufgestellt hat.
Für Scholz ist die Veröffentlichung nicht schlecht, sie drückt seine SPD in
eine Richtung, in der er sie haben will.
Die Bundeswehr gibt sich verwundbar und wiegt den Feind in falscher Sicherheit.
Just saying, so unfähig sind die Damen und Herren der Bundeswehr nun auch nicht.
Also ehrlich gesagt, doch, denke ich schon.
Das ist so ein bisschen die Vermutung, da muss ja mehr dahinter stecken und
so doof können die ja alle gar nicht sein.
Ich glaube, an der Stelle war das halt einfach mal wirklich nur doof und man
fühlt sich in gewisser Hinsicht ein bisschen unangreifbar und denkt halt nicht
so richtig über die Konsequenzen nach und das ist einfach für Bundeswehr nicht so geil.
Und was wir glaube ich in der letzten Debatte dazu auch gar nicht so richtig
gebracht haben, also wenn man mal in so internationale Sicherheitskreise reinhorcht und ich sag mal,
bei meiner Reise in die Ukraine war das häufiger ein Thema, ähm.
Die Bundeswehr hat keinen guten Ruf in der internationalen Militär-Community.
Denen erzählt man einfach gerne mal nicht alles, weil die so in diesem Ruf stehen,
diese Informationen dann zu verbaseln.
Und in der Hinsicht war einfach diese Nummer überhaupt nicht hilfreich.
Also das ist halt einfach, man traut dem Bundeswehrapparat einfach nicht und
die haben einfach generell den Ruf, ein bisschen unprofessionell zu arbeiten,
ihre Technik nicht im Griff zu haben und ich meine, da müssen wir nicht weit gucken,
wie ready die Bundeswehr so ist.
Weißt du, beim Kriegsausbruch so, ja, Panzer, ja, wissen wir auch nicht,
wie viele wir jetzt eigentlich haben und wie viele dann auch funktionieren und
dann müssen wir erstmal gucken, dann müssen wir erstmal eine Bestandsaufnahme machen.
Leute, ihr seid die Bundeswehr, wenn ihr es nicht wisst, wer soll es denn dann wissen?
Also das ist einfach, man hat das Gefühl, dieser ganze Apparat lag einfach jahrzehntelang
komplett brach und wird jetzt das erste Mal daran erinnert, dass er dann unter
Umständen vielleicht dann doch mal zu irgendwas auch ganz gut ist.
Ja, die leisten einfach ständig einen wertvollen Beitrag für den Pazifismus in Deutschland.
Mit großem Erfolg.
Ist in Österreich übrigens auch nicht besser. Ich erinnere mich noch,
unser Geschichtelehrer hat mal gesagt, Österreich ist im Krieg genauso gut wie
im Fußball. Ball. Aber das ist kein Auszeichen.
Gut, letzter Hinweis kommt von Sabrina. Die Tatsache, dass Brigadegeneral Frank
Gräfe Diplom-Informatiker ist, kommt mir in der ganzen Debatte um die digitale
Kommunikation der Bundeswehr irgendwie zu kurz.
Ja, Diplom bei Humboldt gemacht.
Ja. Ich hoffe, das färbt jetzt nicht negativ auf auf Diplom-Informatiker ab. Gut.
Wir werden es in den Kommentaren lesen. Kommen wir zu der nächsten Cyber-Kriegsführung.
Genau, TikTok. TikTok ist jetzt die große Gefahr am Cyber-Himmel und ich habe
das auch nur so ein bisschen am Rande verfolgt,
aber es wird einfach in den USA gerade wild diskutiert, ob man denn irgendwie
TikTok jetzt verbieten sollte oder ob man zumindest TikTok nicht zwangsverkaufen sollte,
Damit es nicht den Chinesen gehört,
weil man jetzt dann doch festgestellt hat, dass TikTok Reichweite hat und nicht
nur das, sondern dass es auch Einfluss hat.
Und Trump findet das ja auch irgendwie und meint auch hier seinen Spezi,
wie heißt der Vogel noch gleich?
Auch einer von seinen korrupten Kabinettsmitgliedern. Ja, ja,
war das dieser Manafort? Ich weiß es jetzt gerade nicht.
Auf jeden Fall, der wäre ja so bereit, das dann irgendwie zu kaufen.
Also überhaupt scheint es gerade so einen extremen Bedarf bei der Hartrechten
zu geben, solche Mediennetzwerke sich einzuverleiben, siehe Elon Musk.
Und ja, möglichst die Kontrolle über diese sozialen Medien zu bekommen,
weil das natürlich auch wirklich ein Ding ist.
Und wenn man sich mal die Zahlen anschaut, gerade in den USA,
wie viele Leute informieren sich jetzt quasi über Social Media und insbesondere
über TikTok versus wie viele Leute beziehen ihre Nachrichten,
aus CNN oder MSNBC oder auch nur aus Fox News.
Da sind halt die sozialen Medien dann doch deutlich weiter.
Also, ich verlinke auch noch so ein interessantes Video von Ryan McBeth,
der sich das mal so unter Sicherheitsaspekten angeschaut hat und dann mal so gesagt hat, okay,
was wäre denn jetzt, wenn ich jetzt hier einen Riot anzetteln möchte und ich
möchte jetzt den Verkehr in irgendeiner größeren amerikanischen Stadt blockieren.
Wie könnte ich denn das mit TikTok machen?
Und geht dann halt einfach zu dem Werbeportal und zeigt einfach mal,
was man da so alles anklicken kann als Targeting, wie man dann entsprechende
Nachrichten machen kann,
wie man mit relativ wenig Geld ein Video produzieren kann,
um halt so eine bestimmte, ich sag mal für einfache Botschaften sehr empfängliche Ziele zu erreichen.
Die Zeit hat und die Aufregungspotenzial hat, die dazu zu bringen,
zu solchen Blockaden aufzurufen.
Mit anderen Worten, man nimmt dann so ein bisschen umweltbewegte Cairns,
die irgendwie leicht sich über alles aufregen und die dann sozusagen als weitere
Multiplikatoren sind, rechnet das ja auch alles irgendwie durch,
was einem das kosten würde und dass man also für relativ wenig Geld schnell
mal über solche Medien Aufregung erzeugen kann.
Und wir sehen ja auch eine ganze Menge solcher Aktionen in der letzten Zeit
und das ist halt ein echtes Problem.
Ja, ich meine, diese Debatte gibt es ja schon seit Trump, die die Angst wieder
gegen China stark geschürt hat.
Wir wissen natürlich jetzt schon über die Beeinflussungsmöglichkeiten,
die sich aus sozialen Netzwerken ergeben, nicht zuletzt aufgrund von deren massiven
Datensammlungspraxen und in der Hinsicht ist TikTok aber überhaupt nicht anders
als Facebook oder YouTube oder andere Plattformen auf diesem Gebiet.
Und was hier diskutiert wird, ist auch kein Datenschutzgesetz auf föderaler Ebene der USA,
wie wir das mit der DSGVO in Europa haben, sondern es ist halt wirklich ein
expliziter Ban von TikTok, der jetzt mit einer sehr großen Mehrheit von 352
zu 65 Stimmen den Kongress passiert hat.
Dieses Gesetz, da hat Biden auch schon angekündigt, dass er das unterschreiben
würde. wurde, aber es müsste noch durch den Senat und da sieht es eher,
Schwierig aus, also da gibt es Stimmen, die einfach dagegen sind,
Regulierung für den Big Tech Bereich überhaupt durchzulassen,
also ob das wirklich passieren wird, wird man erst sehen,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr realer Schritt, der jetzt gesetzt wurde
mit einem konkreten Gesetz,
das halt von ByteDance, der Mutterfirma von TikTok verlangen würde,
TikTok innerhalb von sechs Monaten zu verkaufen.
Ansonsten müsste dieser Dienst in den USA blockiert werden über die bekannten Wege der App-Stores.
Und wahrscheinlich wird man auch die Telekom-Firmen dazu zwingen,
da Netzsperren einzuführen, um so ein Verbot Durchsetzung zu verleihen.
Und das hat natürlich dann jetzt, den Schwenker muss ich mir erlauben,
für europäische Ohren so eine gewisse Ironie, weil wir seit Jahren mit mehreren
höchstgerichtlichen Entscheidungen darum kämpfen,
dass sich doch bitte amerikanische Unternehmen an unsere europäischen Gesetze
halten und da warten wir immer noch drauf,
siehe Schrems 1, Schrems 2, die beiden EuGH-Urteile, die Max gegen Facebook
erwirkt hat und da passiert genau gar nichts.
Nichts auch in Sachen politischem Backing schält sich dann Ursula von der Leyen
neben Joe Biden und im ersten Atemzug geht es um LNG, also Liquid Nitrogen Gas,
um den Gasmangel in Europa zu lindern und im nächsten Atemzug wird über die
Nachfolge vom Privacy Shield gesprochen,
um halt genau diese illegale Praxis in den USA wieder zu verlängern.
Und bei den USA, jetzt wo es auf einmal um China geht, fährt man die härtesten
Geschütze auf, weil man hier….
Angst vor dieser Plattform hat. Also da ist für mich mal auf einer so politischen
Wertigkeitsskala, sehe ich da einen riesigen Mismatch, wo wir uns in Europa
vielleicht auch mal überlegen müssen, wie wir denn unsere Gesetze durchsetzen wollen. wollen.
Und auf der anderen Ebene ist natürlich diese große Debatte,
ist TikTok jetzt gefährlich oder nicht? Ist TikTok gefährlich für unsere Kinder
und Jugendlichen vor allem?
Du hast das erwähnt, also die Reichweite von TikTok ist ungefähr dreimal größer als von CNN.
Das ist schon wirklich eine enorm mächtige Plattform, wenn es um Meinungsmache geht.
Und die Gefahr, dass TikTok jetzt hier für Radikalisierung verwendet wird,
ist teilweise durch Studien unterfüttert, die zum Beispiel sagen,
der pro-palästinensische Content auf TikTok ist weitaus größer und fast künstlich
groß im Vergleich zu dem pro-israelischen Content.
Wir haben das ja an einigen anderen Stellen auch schon diskutiert rund um islamisierenden Content,
wo es ja auch Belege oder zumindest mal so einzelne Fälle gibt,
wo Leute sich wirklich über TikTok dann bis zu der Reise nach Syrien radikalisiert haben.
Ja, und gleichzeitig bin ich da auch schon immer seit Greenberg Analytica so
ein bisschen skeptisch geworden, ob das denn wirklich stimmt at scale,
ob das wirklich sozusagen Einzelfälle sind, sondern wirklich auch die Natur dieses Mediums.
Habt ihr schon ein Unwohlsein? Und es gibt da auch immer mehr Stimmen,
die sagen, gerade für Jugendliche sind diese sozialen Medien,
die so dieses Endless Scrolling als Hauptfeature haben,
vielleicht doch etwas, das man auch aus Jugendschutzperspektive diskutieren sollte. sollte.
Wir verlinken da auch nochmal einen super Podcast von Hardfork zuletzt,
wo ein Verhaltenspsychologe da mit Fokus auf Jugendschutz nochmal auf TikTok
blickt und andere sozialen Medien,
das ist nämlich auch zu bedenken, wenn man jetzt TikTok verbieten würde,
dann hilft das zuerst einmal YouTube und Facebook und Instagram,
weil die natürlich sofort in diesen Markt hineinstechen würden.
In Indien gibt es so einen TikTok-Ban und das hat nur dazu geführt,
dass die amerikanischen Tech-Konzerne jetzt noch viel größere Marktanteile im
indischen Markt halten.
Und was vielleicht noch so zuletzt irgendwie ganz entlarvend ist,
jetzt im Zuge dieser Debatte im Kongress um dieses Gesetz, was da beschlossen
wurde, hat TikTok genau das gemacht, was ihm dieses Gesetz vorwirft.
Nämlich, dass es mit Push-Notification allen seinen Usern empfohlen hat,
sich doch bei ihren gewählten VolksvertreterInnen zu melden und dort gegen dieses Gesetz zu lobbyieren.
Und hat dann dazu geführt, dass die Telefonleitungen im Kongress in die Knie
gegangen sind vor diesem Ansturm.
Ja, also ganz grundsätzlich bleibt für mich so dieser ganz schlechte Nachgeschmack,
dass wir in ein Internet hineinsteuern, wo zusehends Dinge blockiert und zensiert
werden, auch aufgrund von Ansturz.
Politischen und auch machtpolitischen Überlegungen.
Also man kann gerne, also ich glaube, wir brauchen dringend mehr Safeguards
gegen diese Form von Targeted Advertisement
und der Manipulation großer Bevölkerungsschichten, die daraus erwachsen.
Aber die brauchen wir nicht nur bei TikTok, weil dasselbe ist auch möglich über Twitter.
Ich meine, diese Plattform wird durch Maske jetzt eh schon total kaputt gemacht,
aber Aber natürlich gibt es auch da Einflussmöglichkeiten.
Ich freue mich da immer über den Artikel 40 im DSA, der den Zugriff auf die
Daten von so großen Plattformen für die Wissenschaft garantiert.
Weil wir brauchen auf jeden Fall viel mehr Grundlagenforschung,
was diese Technik eigentlich in unserer Gesellschaft anrichtet.
Ich glaube auch, dass wir da neue Gesetze brauchen. Nur ich glaube,
dass die klüger sein müssen als ein einfacher Ben.
Denn besser wäre es, dass wir diese Technik safe machen,
wenn wir irgendwas verbieten, dann vielleicht wirklich nur für junge Menschen da,
wo wir zum Eindruck gekommen sind, dass gewisse Funktionalitäten einfach wirklich
mit sich entwickelnden Gehirnen nicht ganz gesund vereinbar sind.
Aber jetzt einfach so pauschal zu sagen, weil das China ist,
ist es böse und deswegen müssen wir es zensieren, halte ich für falsch.
Und ja, nur so im Zuge dessen, soziale Netzwerke sind halt wirklich inzwischen,
so wie auch früher schon klassische Medien, Stichwort Rupert Murdoch, auch so Machthebel.
Also Truth.Social hat jetzt gerade seinen IPO gehabt und ist jetzt eine Publicly
Traded Company, also am Aktienmarkt und das hat Trump nochmal um drei Milliarden reicher gemacht.
Also wir hatten früher mal Regeln, wie wir so große Medienkonzentrationen eindämmen,
um Demokratie noch möglich zu machen.
Deswegen haben wir öffentlich-rechtliche Medien in Europa, in den USA eher weniger.
Aber die Eigentümerschaft von sozialen Netzwerken ist bedenklich.
Ja, also dass man mit so einem Mastodon-Server so viel Geld machen kann, hätte das gedacht.
Wenn man nur die Leute instrumentalisiert und radikalisiert,
dann ist es auf einmal auch Geld wert.
Und das ist natürlich ein generelles Problem, dass diese ganzen Plattformen
vor allem über eine Radikalisierung der Leute, die daran teilnehmen,
wunderbar funktionieren und Geld verdienen.
Und klar, also Verbote sind schlecht, aber nichts tun ist hier an der Stelle
auch nicht so sehr viel besser und ich habe ehrlich gesagt noch keinen wirklich
überzeugenden Ansatz gesehen, gehört,
der jetzt eigentlich diesem Trend nennenswert etwas entgegenstellen kann.
Ja, hast du schon mal irgendeinen goldenen Weg da durchscheinen sehen irgendwo,
wo man sagen könnte, das könnte jetzt wirklich was bringen und stellt auch bestimmte
Prinzipien nicht so sehr in Frage?
Ich meine, so was so der Konsens in Europa ist, findet sich in Teilen im DSA,
dem Digital Services Act.
Das findet man dort wieder, indem es zum Beispiel auch eine Möglichkeit gibt,
die algorithmische Kuratierung von Inhalten zu beeinflussen.
Also genau wie du sagst, diese Optimierung auf emotionale Reaktionen von Inhalten,
die dann ganz oft dazu führen, dass es immer extremere Inhalte werden,
die einem ausgespielt werden, dass man da einfach mit einer Agency der einzelnen.
Userinnen und User so ein bisschen dagegen hält.
Das wäre so ein Ansatz, wobei das ist eher ein sanfter, ob der reichen wird,
ob das dann vielleicht auch bei Zwölfjährigen ankommt, dass das was ist,
das man vielleicht einstellt, weil es ist ja unser Gehirn, dass sich da,
dass ja diese Dinge sehen will auf einer gewissen Ebene, wenn das was mit uns tut.
Gut, das ist so wie der Autounfall, wo man nicht wegschauen kann.
Und natürlich ist mehr Transparenz über das, was auf diesen Plattformen abgeht,
wichtig. Und das kann auch nur durch unabhängige Wissenschaft passieren.
Und am Ende gibt es natürlich auch so gewisse Momente oder Perspektiven oder
Krisen, zu denen Plattformen anders agieren müssen.
Das haben wir in der Pandemie gesehen, das sehen wir rund um Wahlen,
das sehen wir auch bei den Kriegen, die es gerade gibt.
Und das sind aber alles noch sehr sanfte Stellschrauben, die wir jetzt hier geschaffen haben.
Die sind auch alle noch so frisch, dass man noch nicht sagen kann,
ob die was helfen würden.
Ich glaube, nach diesem Superwahljahr 2024 werden wir ein bisschen besser wissen,
was davon was gebracht hat.
Aber wenn die bisherige Erfahrung, wie gut sich Tech-Plattformen an unsere Gesetze
halten, irgendein Indiz sind, dann ist meine Hoffnung enden wollend.
Also ich kann verstehen, wieso Leute sagen, wir müssen das jetzt verbieten,
aber dann, dass sich dann am Ende Mark Zuckerberg freuen kann,
dass Instagram noch größer wird, hat die Welt dann halt auch nicht besser gemacht. macht.
Hm. Naja, also ich bin mir auch manchmal nicht so sicher, ob das Problem die,
sich noch entwickelnden Gehirne sind oder eher die, die sich bisher noch gar
nicht so richtig die aufgehört haben, sich zu entwickeln.
Der scheint mir manchmal noch das größere Problem zu sein. Na gut.
Let's move on. Es gibt Neuigkeiten im Fall von,
der Auslieferung von Von Julian Assange, die stand ja jetzt zur Diskussion,
oder steht schon lange zur Diskussion, also die Auslieferung von Großbritannien an die USA.
Da wurde jetzt nochmal geklagt und es gab eine Entscheidung des Royal Court
of Justice in London, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ganz genau. Dieses Verfahren wurde zuerst im Februar diesen Jahres mal verhandelt
und jetzt gab es gestern diese Entscheidung des Royal Court of Justice in London,
der den Berufungsantrag von Julian Assange gegen seine Auslieferung in die USA
in mehreren Punkten als begründet und stichhaltig befunden hat.
Was das bedeutet ist, dass diese drohende Auslieferung in die USA zumindest
jetzt mal vorläufig gestoppt ist.
Dort drohen Julian ja 175 Jahre Haftstrafe wegen dem Espionage Act.
Also er wird dort wegen Spionage angeklagt, was auch für die USA das erste Mal
ist, dass ein Herausgeber einer Medienplattform wegen Spionage angeklagt wird,
Förster-Mandment und so.
Und auch Hacking wird ihm zur Last gelegt, also Computerkriminalität.
Konkret bedeutet diese Entscheidung, dass die US-Regierung jetzt einige Zusicherungen
im Fall Assange machen muss.
Die erste Zusicherung ist, dass das First Amendment in seinem Fall geltend gemacht
werden muss. Das heißt, dass die Amis ihm nicht das Grundrecht auf Meinungsfreiheit
strittig machen können.
Und das ist natürlich, gerade weil es hier um Journalismus geht,
eine ganz große Sache, weil daran hängt natürlich auch die Pressefreiheit.
Der zweite Punkt ist, dass die Todesstrafe ausgeschlossen werden muss,
die könnte ihm nämlich auch in den USA drohen.
Und die dritte Sache ist, dass Julian Assange, der australische Staatsbürger
ist, nicht aufgrund seiner australischen Staatsbürgerschaft schlechter gestellt werden.
Und das ist gerade sehr spannend, weil der erste und der dritte Punkt sind ein
bisschen im Widerspruch miteinander.
In den USA gibt es ja Bürgerrechte, wir erinnern uns an diese ganzen Verfassungszusätze
dort und in der amerikanischen Rechtsordnung sind aber diese Grundrechte,
wie wir sie nennen würden, nur Bürgerinnenrechte.
Sprich, die sind nur für Menschen mit amerikanischer Staatsbürgerschaft.
Und das bedeutet, dass man da auch als Europäer zum Beispiel keinerlei Grundrechte
hat, die verfassungsmäßig garantiert werden.
Das ist auch immer bei den ganzen Entscheidungen rund um Datenschutz ein wichtiges Element.
Und gleichzeitig in Europa und auch auf UNO-Ebene gibt es ja die Menschenrechtskonvention.
Und es gibt natürlich auch in Europa so die Grundrechte-Charta.
Das ist der Unterschied zwischen diesen Begriffen. Ein Bürgerrecht gilt nur
für die Menschen mit Staatsbürgerschaft und ein Grund- oder Menschenrecht gilt universell für alle.
Und deswegen ist das irgendwie ganz spannend, dass die sagen,
ihr könnt ihm dieses ganz wichtige Grundrecht in den USA, wo es natürlich auch
ganz viel Rechtsprechung gibt, nicht strittig machen.
Und bezüglich der Todesstrafe, das ist natürlich eine ganz wichtige Zusicherung.
Mein Eindruck war immer, dass die Amis Assange nicht zum Märtyrer machen wollen,
sondern eher schauen, dass er vergessen wird.
Und hier hat auch der Protest, glaube ich, schon Wirkung gezeigt,
den es in den letzten Wochen und Monaten gegeben hat.
Auch die Frau von Assange ist hier ja in den Medien sehr aktiv und eloquent
dabei, ihren Ehemann zu verteidigen und das hat jetzt zumindest mal zu diesem Aufschub geführt.
Bis zum 16. April gilt, bis dahin müssen die USA sozusagen diese Zusicherungen
abgeben oder eben nicht.
Und andernfalls wird die Anhörung dann wahrscheinlich so im 20.
Mai fortgesetzt, wie es dann überhaupt weitergeht. Und ganz wichtig ist halt nochmal zu sagen,
Assange war jetzt auch bei dem Prozess gar nicht mehr anwesend,
weil seine Gesundheitssituation scheinbar jetzt schon so schlecht geworden ist.
Der sitzt seit 2019 in Einzelhaft in einem Hochsicherheitsgefängnis,
dass er da eben gar nicht mehr in der Lage war, auch nur virtuell am Gerichtsprozess teilzunehmen.
Wir verlinken da auch nochmal ein Interview mit einer Reporterin,
die vor Ort war im Gerichtssaal.
Es gab nämlich auch nochmal Probleme, was den Zugang der Öffentlichkeit und
von Journalistinnen im Gerichtssaal betrifft, um diesem Verfahren überhaupt zu folgen.
Deswegen, was nochmal so ein Treppenwitz der Informationsfreiheit ist,
dass der Köster-Aufdecker der letzten Jahrzehnte in einem Verfahren,
was fast unter Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit stattfindet, vielleicht ausgeliefert werden soll.
Also das ist weiterhin ein wichtiger Fall und deswegen haben wir das hier nochmal vermeldet.
Sehe ich das jetzt richtig? Also auf der einen Seite heißt es,
er darf jetzt Berufung einlegen, auf der anderen Seite heißt es, wenn bis zum 16.
April die Zusicherungen eingereicht werden der USA, dann dürfte auch ausgeliefert werden.
Also ist jetzt so oder so nochmal Berufung möglich oder nur,
wenn die USA die Zusicherung nicht macht?
Soweit ich das verstanden habe, würden diese drei Zusicherungen gegeben,
dann könnte er ausgeliefert werden.
Wenn das nicht passiert, dann wird das Verfahren am 20. Mai fortgesetzt.
So verstehe ich das jetzt gerade hier.
Ich weiß aus sonstigen Medienberichten, dass die anderen Punkte,
die die Verteidigung vorbringen wollte, nicht wirklich gehört werden.
Da gab es Beweisanträge, die sich auch darauf beziehen, dass das Team von Assange
meint, es gäbe konkrete Pläne, ihn umzubringen und da wollten sie Beweise vorlegen
und das haben die Richter aber scheinbar nicht zugelassen.
Also wir sind jetzt nicht in einem normalen Verfahren, wo vollumfänglich wieder geprüft wird.
Es ist ja auch strittig, ob diese Auslieferung, die die Armees beantragt haben
und 2022 Innenminister Patel in Großbritannien zugestimmt hat,
ob das überhaupt rechtens war.
Weil die Verteidigung meint, dass das ein politischer Strafprozess ist und deswegen
an dem Auslieferungsgesuch der Amerikaner gar nicht hätte zustimmen dürfen.
Alles ein bisschen vertrackt.
Naja, dass das ein politischer Prozess ist, ist glaube ich vollkommen unstrittig.
Gut, sehen wir mal, wie es da weitergeht. So, schauen wir mal nach Europa.
Ja.
Da gab es einen Beschluss des Europäischen Gerichtshofs für Menschenrechte,
kurz EGMR. Worum ging es denn da?
Ja, das ist ein schöner Fall. Der freut mich, dass wir den bringen können.
Und zwar hat der EGMR ein Urteil gefällt, das sehr, sehr gut ist für unser Recht
auf Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung.
Wir haben diese Debatte ja die ganze Zeit, wir kommen auch später noch zur Chatkontrolle,
aber Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung ist ja die ganze Zeit unter Gefahr und es
gibt da starke Bestrebungen,
das einzuschränken und deswegen ist dieses Urteil vom EGMR wirklich ein Grund zur Freude.
Und ich brauche gerade eine Hilfe bei der Aussprache dieses russischen Namen.
Es ist der Name Potschasow gegen Russland.
Potschasow wie Russia.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da eine große Hilfe bin, aber so würde ich es auch aussprechen.
Okay, also der Herr Potschasow.
Potsapov, danke. Hat da geklagt. Wie kam es dazu?
Es gab in Russland eine Gesetzesverschärfung, die sowas wie eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung etabliert hat,
aber nicht nur wie wir das kennen, eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung bei den Internetanbietern,
sondern auch bei den Inhalteanbietern.
Die sollen eben auch Verkehrsdaten und Inhaltsdaten auf Vorrat speichern,
damit die Strafverfolgungsbehörden hier drauf zugreifen können.
Und dagegen hat sich Telegram gewährt mit dem Argument, wir sind doch verschlüsselt
und wir können diese Dinge gar nicht sperren.
Da hat der FSB sich aber nicht davon abhalten lassen. Der FSB ist der Inlandsgeheimdienst
in Russland, der Nachfolger des KGB.
Die wollten da Daten zu einem Terrorverdächtigen haben.
Telegram hat sich geweigert und wurde auch in der Folge zwei Jahre lang in Russland gesperrt.
Und diese Sperre von Telegram ist auf der einen Seite natürlich mit ganz vielen
VPNs umgangen worden, hat auch am Ende nicht gehalten, inzwischen ist diese Sperre aufgehoben.
Aber in dieser Zeit gab es halt mehrere Menschen in Russland,
die sich da versucht haben, gerichtlich dagegen zu wehren.
Und einer davon war halt der Herr Potschasow, der mit seiner Klage bis zum EGMR
gekommen ist und dort jetzt auch Erfolg hatte.
Der EGMR hat nämlich jetzt entschieden, das Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung abzuschwächen,
zu anlassloser Massenüberwachung führt.
Und dass das insgesamt ein Verstoß gegen das Grundrecht auf Privatsphäre ist.
Und das ist wirklich eine ganz wichtige Brücke, die hier geschlagen wird,
sozusagen die Existenz von Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung aufzuweichen.
Die Daten von einer Masse von Menschen dieser anlasslosen Massenüberwachung
zuführen würde und deswegen schon allein dieses Aufweichen der Verschlüsselung
kein zulässiges staatliches Mittel ist.
Das ist mal sehr bezeichnend und dann das zweite, was sehr bezeichnend ist an
diesem Fall, ist, dass das eben der FSB war,
der hier auf der anderen Seite stand für Russland und versucht hat,
diese Daten zu bekommen, weil wir kennen das aus anderen Urteilen auch im Bereich
der Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Der hatte EuGH in den letzten Jahren auch so Ausnahmen geschaffen,
dass er sagt, naja, für Strafverfolgungsbehörden Vorratsdatenspeicherung geht
eigentlich nicht, aber nationale Sicherheit, da könnten nochmal andere Regeln gelten.
Und ein Inlandsgeheimdienst ist natürlich genau für diese nationale Sicherheit
zuständig, also nicht für normale Strafverfolgung, sondern für Gefahrenabwehr.
Und dass trotzdem hier der EGMR zu diesem Urteil gekommen ist,
ist natürlich eine extra super gute Nachricht für alle Menschen,
die sich für Datenschutz gegen Überwachung und für Verschlüsselung einsetzen.
Das ist aus der Perspektive schon mal wirklich gut und deswegen auch was,
das wir auf jeden Fall melden wollten.
Ich wollte noch ein paar Fun Facts angeben, nämlich dass Russland damals natürlich
noch Teil war vom Europarat.
Der Europarat ist ja das Gremium, zu dem der EGMR gehört.
Seit 2022 ist Russland da ja ausgeschlossen worden.
Trotzdem hat der Gerichtshof jetzt noch dieses Urteil gefällt,
was ich auch nochmal irgendwie ganz spannend finde, weil die hätten natürlich
sagen können, nee, ist irrelevant, lass mal beim Tisch rüberfallen.
Sondern nein, sie haben wirklich diesen Fall aufgegriffen, was komplett die
Entscheidung des Gerichtshofs ist, was die Wahlen entscheiden,
da kann ihnen keiner dreinreden und haben trotzdem eben dieses wichtige Grundsatzurteil
gefällt. Also das ist ein guter Tag.
Genau, aber es ist nochmal ganz wichtig, diese Unterscheidungen zu machen,
weil das ist ja alles sehr verwirrend immer, wenn wir von Europa reden,
dann nehmen wir immer irgendwie an, dass das irgendwas mit der Europäischen
Union zu tun hat, das ist im Falle des EGMR eben nicht so, sondern hier steht
eben der Europarat und das ist eben nicht der Grund,
Der Rat der Europäischen Union, den es ja auch nochmal gibt,
also einer der drei konstituierenden Gruppen der Europäischen Union,
neben Kommission und Parlament gibt es halt diesen Rat der Europäischen Union,
der sich ja aus den Mitgliedstaaten, also den Regierungen der Mitgliedstaaten zusammensetzt.
Und der normale Europarat ist halt dann eben wirklich Europa und dann eben inklusive
eigentlich aller Länder, eben jetzt mit der Ausnahme von Russland und Belarus,
die halt ausgenommen wurden durch diesen Ukraine-Krieg.
Aber ansonsten sind halt eigentlich alle dabei.
Also Skandinavien, Schweiz, Island, alles was sonst immer so ein bisschen außen vor ist.
Was auch so ein bisschen einem natürlich auch immer sagt, dass es so mit dieser
Bindung dann auch nicht so weit her ist.
Weil wenn irgendwelche Länder was zu befürchten haben von so einer Organisation,
dann sind sie halt im Zweifelsfall auch eher nicht Mitglied.
Ja, also der Europarat sieht sich selber auch in seinem Selbstverständnis so
als der Hüter von allen Grundrechten, die sagen so, hey,
wir haben es erfunden und sind deswegen aber in den nicht bindenden Papieren,
die sie produzieren, teilweise gar nicht so schlecht.
Also die gehen mit manchmal dem richtigen Anspruch daran.
Das ist oft auch dann in der politischen Auseinandersetzung für uns Aktivistikern
gut, wenn wir auf gute Papiere vom Europarat zurückgreifen können.
Aber es ist wie du sagst, also bindende Wirkung hat das an sich nicht,
was dort entschieden wird.
Der EGMR an sich schon, also das sind schon Urteile, die eigentlich für alle,
aber zumindest für den Einzelfall dann doch eine Konsequenz haben. haben.
Jetzt in dem Fall von Russland ist das glaube ich zu vernachlässigen,
aber für die ganzen anderen Länder, wo Verschlüsselung aufgeweicht wird,
da können wir uns auf jeden Fall auf dieses neue gute Urteil berufen.
Ja also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es jetzt gar keine Auswirkung auf die EU
hätte, aber es ist eben keine rechtliche unmittelbare Bindung, sondern eher so eine,
Ich sag mal, ethisch-moralische Kette, oder?
Also als gutes Scheidungskind kenne ich das gut. Der EGMR und der EuGH sind
die ganze Zeit in so einem Battle.
Wer ist jetzt der bessere Höchstgerichtshof für Grundrechte?
Und da kann man sich sehr schön gegeneinander ausspielen und versuchen zu schauen,
wer einen jetzt mehr lieb hat und von wem man mehr bekommt und sich immer auf
den anderen berufen, da wo es passt.
Also das ist schon im Dialog.
Was, du willst mir keine Switch kaufen? Ich halte es zum anderen Elternteil.
Genau. Gut. Mich verwirrt das, dass sie auch die Europa-Flagge verwenden beim Europarat.
Ja, das ist bewusst verwirrend gemacht.
Das ist einfach... Verstehe es nicht. Und auch die selbe Hürde.
Frechheit. Können die sich nicht was Eigenes einfallen lassen?
Wirklich, die haben auch die Ode an die Vordel? Das ist schade.
Da hätte man sich schon...
Irgendein Metal-Lied. Metal und Nationalhymnen sind eh nicht voneinander zu
unterscheiden. Fuck. Naja.
Alright. So, dann kommen wir zu einer anderen schönen Wortschöpfung,
die, glaube ich, mal hier ihren Ursprung gehabt hat.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Logbuch Netzpolitik oder Netzpolitik.org war.
Ich finde den Begriff super und ärgere mich voll, dass er mir nicht selber eingefallen ist.
Mir ist er eingefallen.
Dir ist er eingefallen? Ah, perfekt.
Ah, danke.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob er nicht auch anderen auch noch eingefallen ist,
unabhängig von mir, aber mir ist er in der Sendung in dem Moment eingefallen.
Nämlich das Leitungsschutzrecht.
Ganz genau. Worum geht es? Es geht um das Thema Netzgebühren oder Internetmaut,
das wir hier schon ein paar Mal diskutiert haben.
Das ist eine unleidige Debatte, die uns seit 2022 plagt.
Wer sich erinnert, das war gerade der Moment der großen Freude,
Netzneutralität in Europa endlich abgeschlossen, alles erreicht,
worum es ging, Zero Rating ist verboten, Stream On und Vodafone Pass wurden
ja damals dann auch aus dem deutschen Markt gekickt.
Und wir haben uns gefreut und dachten Netzneutralität ist erledigt und endlich spannendere Themen.
Aber mitnichten. Es hat nämlich dann die Telekom-Industrie zum Gegenschlag ausgeholt
und eine Debatte eröffnet rund um ihr Verlangen doch bitte Geld zu bekommen
von den Inhalteanbietern,
die Daten in ihr Netz schicken.
Und diese Debatte ist jetzt schon eben seit viel zu langer Zeit am Köcheln.
Vor allem in Brüssel ist das auch wirklich nicht tot zu kriegen,
weil da sehr, sehr, sehr viel Lobbygeld darauf geworfen wird und fast jede andere
Woche nochmal ein Event der Telekom-Industrie passiert, wo die Leute eingekocht werden.
Und es gab auch gerade wieder neue Bestrebungen von Digitalkommissar Thierry
Breton, auf die ich gleich kommen werde.
Dieser Herr Breton ist ja wirklich ein würdiger Nachfolger für Günther Oettinger.
Aber ich wollte mal anfangen mit den Grundlagen.
Nicht nur das, er ist ja auch ehemaliger Mitglied der, wo war er nochmal gleich,
Mitglied bei der Telekom, Thompson & Orange oder so.
Franz Telekom CEO war er einige Jahre.
Sprich, er war Chef des französischen Telekom Incumbents, was heute Orange ist.
Also er kommt aus der Branche. Er hat gute Kontakte in diese Richtung. Und.
Beziehungsweise die Branche hat ganz gute Kontakte zu ihm.
Ja, ich glaube es gibt da keinen großen Unterschied zwischen der Branche und ihm.
Aber wir sollten mit den Basics anfangen und zwar wollte ich mal hier in der
Sendung erklären, wie der Interconnection-Markt überhaupt funktioniert.
Weil ich merke immer öfter, dass es da so eine kleine Wissenslücke gibt und
ich versuche das jetzt einfach darzustellen. Das Internet ist ja ein Netz von Netzen.
Wie es schon im Namen steckt, das Internet besteht aus autonomen einzelnen Netzen,
sogenannten Autonomous Systems, die sich im sogenannten Interconnection-Bereich
oder Markt zusammenschalten.
Das bedeutet, dass einfach einzelne Netze physische Kabel hingelegt haben,
sodass Daten da fließen können.
Es gibt auch die zugehörigen Routing-Protokolle, die mit einer wirklich bahnbrechenden
Komplexität umgehen können, wie diese Daten dann logisch zu leiten sind in diesen
einzelnen Netzen, sodass die immer an ihr Ziel kommen.
Und natürlich gibt es hier unterschiedliche Arten von Netzen.
Wir haben einerseits mal unsere Internetanbieter, die natürlich ihr eigenes
Netz betreiben und wir haben Inhalteanbieter, die oft dann hosten in den Netzen von anderen.
Wenn ich zum Beispiel bei Hetzner meinen Server habe,
dann ist das ein eigenes Netz, wo meine Daten sozusagen liegen und andere Hoster
haben aber auch einfach nur ihre Server in irgendeinem Netz von einem Internetanbieter stehen.
Und es gibt auch diese ganz großen Internetkonzerne wie zum Beispiel Apple,
die ihr eigenes Netzwerk betreiben und dann sozusagen auch ganz viele Daten
natürlich auch von dort in den Rest des Internets schicken.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Apple das beste Beispiel ist, also Google war ja glaube
ich überhaupt das erste Unternehmen,
was das so betrieben hat und dann muss man auch nochmal Netflix nennen,
das sind ja auch in dieser ganzen Debatte diejenigen, die jetzt vor allem herausgekramt
werden, wenn es um Apple geht.
Traffic geht, also um große Mengen, also YouTube, Videoportale etc.
Aber natürlich auch Facebook und Meta und Apple natürlich auch.
Also alle, die große Clouds anbieten, bauen auch ihre eigenen Infrastrukturen weltweit auf.
Genau, du hast recht. Apple hat halt irgendwie so diesen ganzen IP-Block,
weswegen ich gerade an sie dachte, aber du hast recht, Apple verwendet auch sehr stark CDNs,
um ihre Inhalte sehr schnell an die Endnutzerinnen zu bringen.
Und CDNs sind einfach sozusagen nochmal optimierte Hoster, die sehr viel tun
dafür, dass die Daten wirklich schnell und möglichst geografisch auch nahe an die Endkunden kommen.
Aber sie haben vor allem auch eigene internationale Leitungen,
damit sie eben da nicht von anderen abhängen und bauen eben auch wirklich ein
eigenes Netz nochmal mit auf, wie auch immer das dann vertraglich geregelt ist.
Ganz genau. Und du hast recht, auch viele der Unterseekabler gehören inzwischen Big Tech Konzernen.
Das kommt auch nochmal dazu in der Debatte, über die wir gleich sprechen werden.
Aber auf einer grundlegenden Ebene ist es mir wichtig zu erklären,
dass in dieser Zusammenschaltung eigentlich der allergrößte Teil der Verbindungen,
die da geschlossen werden, wirklich mit Handschlag funktionieren.
Also es gibt da Zahlen von der OECD von 95 Prozent der Zusammenschaltungsvereinbarungen,
die wirklich ohne irgendein Schriftstück einfach so geschlossen werden,
hey, mein Link ist da schon verstopft, kannst du noch ein Kabel reinstecken und wird gemacht.
Da fließt teilweise auch Geld, aber das ist sehr oft wirklich nur geschlossener.
Eigenen Kosten, die halt entstehen dadurch, dass du da einen Port hast und ein Kabel reinsteckst.
Also wir reden von minimalen Kosten
im Vergleich zu den sonstigen Gestehungskosten von so einem Netzwerk.
Da ist es viel, viel teurer, Funkmasten aufzustellen, sich Frequenzen zu besorgen,
Customer Management zu machen.
All das ist wirklich x-fach mehr teuer, als es normalerweise kostet,
wenn ich Daten zwischen Netzen austauschen will. Es gibt zwei Arten grob,
wie so eine Zusammenschaltung funktioniert. Das eine ist das sogenannte Peering.
Dem liegt oft die Annahme zugrunde, dass es die Datenvolumina,
die da ausgetauscht werden, in beide Richtungen annähernd symmetrisch sind und
deswegen schaltet man sich dann einfach zusammen.
Das macht das Leben für alle einfacher, weil dann gibt es eine direkte Verbindung
zwischen zwei Netzen, die viel miteinander reden.
Und die zweite Variante, die es noch gibt, ist das sogenannte Transit.
Das bedeutet, dass man, um an den Rest des Internets zu kommen,
mit dem man keine bilateralen Zusammenschaltungsvereinbarungen hat,
zahlt man, um sozusagen in das übrige Internet die eigenen Daten abliefern zu können.
Und dieser Transit, da gibt es auch mehrere Anbieter, die in diesem Bereich
aktiv sind und da ist es zum Beispiel auch so, dass man sich die Preislisten anschauen kann.
Das ist halt auch sicherlich teurer als Peering, aber immer noch vertretbar.
Und vor allem, man bezieht auch nur Transit für alle Netze, mit denen man sich
eben sonst nicht irgendwie zusammenschalten kann.
Eigentlich wollen alle lieber pieren, weil das ist für alle billiger.
Und Transit nimmst du eigentlich nur für den Rest, der übrig bleibt.
Damit du halt noch irgendwie nach Timbuktu kommst oder nach Buenos Aires.
Und der Grundgedanke im ganzen Interconnection-Bereich ist, dass das Internet
mehr ist als die Summe seiner Teile.
Diese globale Konnektivität auf Augenhöhe, die wir uns damit geschaffen haben,
ist etwas, das aus einem Gedanken,
dass wir teilen hier Kapazitäten der Verbindung, damit unsere User auch das
Angebot Internet nutzen können.
Das ist vielleicht nochmal ganz wichtig festzuhalten, das Netzneutralitätsgesetz
in Europa gibt uns allen das Recht, mit dem gesamten Internet verbunden zu werden
und nicht nur teilen davon. davon.
Virtually all endpoints ist in Artikel 3.1 eines der Grundrechte,
die allen Inhalteanbietern und Endnutzern gegeben sind, damit wir halt sowas
wie ein gesamtes Internet haben.
An diesem Prinzip, das eben auch schon sehr alt ist, das kommt wirklich von
den Anfängen des Internets und ist auch immer noch, ich sage mal in fast allen
Netzen, bis auf ein paar wenige große, der Modus operandi, wie Daten ausgetauscht werden.
An dem liegt zugrunde das Prinzip Bill and Keep.
Du kriegst dein Geld als Internetanbieter von deinen eigenen Kunden und diese
minimalen Kosten für die Zusammenschaltung, die gibst du eigentlich nicht weiter
oder das sind nur die Sachkosten, die du verrechnest.
Du versuchst nicht, dein Geld mit den Kunden von anderen Firmen zu verdienen,
sondern von deinen eigenen Kunden. Bill and Keep.
Das ist eigentlich so die schöne Welt des Internets, wie sie mal war und wie
sie auch immer noch in vielen Teilen gelebt wird.
Und dann gibt es einige wenige große Internetanbieter wie die Deutsche Telekom,
die hier davon abweichen und zwar sehr drastisch davon abweichen.
Das merkt man daran, dass die sagen, wir pieren mit niemandem.
Wir schließen uns nicht einfach so zusammen mit anderen Netzen.
Wir tun hier nicht, was alle anderen tun, um das Internet überhaupt möglich
zu machen, Sondern wir wollen immer Geld haben, weil du von uns auch nur Transit kaufen kannst.
Und unser Transit ist der beste der ganzen Welt. Der kostet x-fach mehr als
jeder andere Transit, den du kaufen kannst.
Und auch wenn du schon verbunden bist mit dem restlichen Internet und eigentlich
nur die Kunden von uns, der tollen deutschen Telekom, erreichen willst und in
unser wunderbares Netz hinein willst, da musst du uns das halt extra zahlen.
Das ist so etwas, das natürlich dann, wenn man es sich durchdenkt,
dazu führt, dass wir de facto bei bezahlten Überholspuren sind.
Du bist nur gut erreichbar für die Kunden der Deutschen Telekom,
wenn du der Deutschen Telekom Geld zahlst.
Ansonsten bist du gezwungen, über sonstige Schleichwege in dein Netz reinzukommen
und die sind halt dauerhaft verstopft.
Die sind die ganze Zeit, wie man sagt, congested.
Also da wirst du nur mit einem signifikanten Paketsverlust in dieses Netz kommen
und dadurch natürlich einen Dienst anbieten,
der viel schlechter ist als der deiner Konkurrenz, die sich schon auf solche
bezahlten Deals eingelassen hat mit der Deutung Telekom.
Die Telekom verkauft einen sozusagen doppelt. Also auf der einen Seite muss
man dafür zahlen, dass man irgendwie angeschlossen wird Und auf der anderen
Seite sollen andere nochmal dafür bezahlen, dass man auch erreicht wird,
obwohl man ja eigentlich genau dafür bezahlt, dass man erreicht wird.
Korrekt.
Also nicht, dass ich erreichen kann, sondern auch, dass ich erreicht werde.
Und im Prinzip ist das halt hier schon mal ein doppelter Verkauf.
Und das ist natürlich gerade im Hinblick der Telekom ein problematischer Fall,
weil ja oft auch die Telekom im Prinzip die Grundversorgung darstellt,
weil ich ja gar keine andere Möglichkeit habe, ins Internet zu gehen, als über die Telekom.
Gut, das ändert sich jetzt mit der Zeit, aber das war definitiv für lange Zeit
der Fall und ist es sicherlich in manchen Bereichen auch immer noch und von
daher kann man das ja sozusagen als Kunde auch gar nicht steuern.
Das heißt man ist mehr oder weniger, wenn man im Internet teilnehmen will und
das will man oder muss man mittlerweile eigentlich auch schon fast,
Stichwort Grundversorgung, gezwungen darüber diesen Weg zu gehen und das arbeitet
dann eben die Telekom als Vorteil für sich heraus und sagt irgendwie so, ja okay,
schönen Anschluss haben sie da, wäre doch doof.
Wenn er nicht erreicht werden würde.
Genau, und dieses Faustpfand, als dass man da als Kundin der Deutschen Telekom missbraucht wird,
ist halt etwas, das auch wirklich schlecht ist für den Internetmarkt als solchen,
weil es natürlich das Ausnutzen ihrer marktdominanten Stellung ist.
Und dieses Prinzip, dass man bezahlt werden will dafür, dass die eigenen Kunden
erreichbar sind oder erreicht werden von anderen, Das ist nicht neu.
Das kennen wir schon aus der Telefon-Ära.
Dort gab es das Prinzip von Calling Party Pays.
Also die anrufende Seite, das anrufende Netz bezahlt das Netz,
in dem dieser Anruf terminiert wird, also entgegengenommen, mit sogenannten
Terminierungsentgelten dafür, dass dieser Anruf zugestellt wird.
Und das war schon in der Telefon-Ära etwas, das massiv dazu geführt hat,
dass es keinen Wettbewerb gab.
Weil wenn du einmal groß genug einen Kundenstamm hast, dann sitzt du sehr komfortabel
auf deinen Händen und musst eigentlich nichts mehr tun,
weil du sowieso viel mehr Geld verdienst als jeder kleine Challenger,
der erstmal seinen Kundenstock aufbauen muss und natürlich auch viel weniger
Geld von den anderen für seine Bestandskunden bekommt.
Aber im Internet macht das natürlich noch mal viel weniger Sinn,
denn es ist ja nicht Google, die mir die YouTube-Datenpakete einseitig mutwillig
schickt, sondern die werden ja von den zahlenden Kunden angefordert.
Das ist ja die Dienstleistung, die die von der Deutschen Telekom gekauft haben,
beliebige Dienste im Internet abrufen zu können. Und oft eben auch gerade im
Mobilfunk mit Volumentarifen, sprich es ist wirklich das konkrete Datenpaket, was hier bezahlt wird.
Ja, das ist so der Kern von dem Wahnsinn dieser politischen Forderung,
mit der wir uns seit 2022 konfrontiert sind.
Es gab da schon eine große Konsultation letztes Jahr.
Wir eigentlich haushoch gewonnen haben, also die Koalition, die damals auf unserer Seite stand,
war wirklich von öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien bis zu Privatmedien,
von Konsumentenschutzorganisationen bis zu allen Big Techs, die es gibt auf
der Welt, von uns Netzaktivisten bis zur Urheberrechtsindustrie.
Disney war da auf unserer Seite.
Wir hatten die kleinen Internetanbieter, die Internet Exchanges wie Dezix,
Deutsche Glasfaser, also die, die wirklich das Netz bauen und zusammenschalten,
haben alle gesagt, Leute, wir haben ein Problem mit der Resilienz.
Eine neue Pandemie könnten wir vielleicht nicht mehr so gut ab,
wenn wir hier so einen überregulierten Interconnection-Markt haben.
Und am Ende war es auch die Monopolkommission, die gesagt hat,
das riecht nach was ganz, ganz Schlimmes so als Wettbewerbssicht.
Wir haben die Medienregulierungsbehörden in Deutschland gehabt,
die gesagt haben, das ist schlecht für den Medienpluralismus und die Telekom-Regulierungsbehörden,
Barrack, BNetz A, haben alle gesagt, hey, das verstößt gegen die Netzneutralität.
Trotzdem, obwohl dann niemand anderer als die Telcos gesagt haben, das ist eine geile Idee,
haben wir jetzt seit ein paar Wochen ein neues White Paper von der EU-Kommission,
in dem genau diese Idee der Netzgebühren, des Leitungsschutzrechts gefordert
wird und das eben zum Gesetz zu machen.
Man sagt da zwar, es gibt kein Marktversagen, aber wir wollen das trotzdem.
Wir wollen trotzdem so eine Schlichtungsstelle, wo man sich hinwenden kann und
dann dieser Preis festgelegt wird von den Regulierungsbehörden.
Sprich, ich brauche eine Regulierung der Preise vom Interconnection-Markt.
Damit wird dieses ganze Konstrukt natürlich von einem total unregulierten Markt,
der es heute ist, zu einem Markt,
wo eine Regulierungsbehörde Preise festsetzen wird und damit diese Zusammenschaltung
nicht mehr so einfach möglich sein wird,
weil eben nicht mehr Stabilität des Netzes und Qualität des Dienstes die entscheidenden
Kriterien sind, sondern Gewinnoptimierung.
Das kennen wir von diesen großen Konzernen und das würde so eine Verhandlungspflicht
zwingend dann auch bedeuten.
Und das Spannende ist noch, was ansonsten in diesem White Paper drinnen ist,
nämlich Marktkonsolidierung.
Also man sagt da ganz klar, wir wollen….
Viel weniger, viel größere Internetanbieter, die dann bitte auch pan-europäisch
operieren sollen, also weniger Wettbewerb.
Die eine Sache, die Preise für Internet in Europa runtergebracht hat in den
letzten Jahrzehnten, dass man mit Regulierung Wettbewerb garantiert hat,
das will die Kommission jetzt zurückschrauben.
Und das ist natürlich super desaströs, weil der gemeinsame Nenner von diesen
beiden Forderungen heißt einfach höhere Preise für Endnutzerinnen, für Konsumentinnen.
Und das in Zeiten einer Rekordinflation. Also ich hoffe, dass das vielleicht
im Rahmen der EU-Wahl ein bisschen debattiert wird.
Auch vielleicht in liberalen Kreisen, für die Thierry Breton ja antritt als
EU-Kommissar, der von Frankreich, von der liberalen Partei Macons ins Rennen geschickt wird.
Und Breton hat diese Konsultation gerade gestartet mit einer Deadline am 30.
Juni, also nach der EU-Wahl. Also die Strategie ist ganz klar,
er will die Hand der nächsten Kommission binden, um ja zu schauen,
dass diese Ideen der Telekom-Industrie in irgendeiner Form umgesetzt werden.
Deutschland ist da bisher sehr kritisch, es gibt auch im April einen Workshop
dazu in Berlin vom deutschen Digitalisierungs- und Verkehrsministerium und die
Debatte ist jetzt wieder neu angezündet worden.
Ich frage mich ein bisschen, was neue Argumente jetzt noch bringen sollen,
weil die Argumente liegen alle schon am Tisch.
Aber Herr Breton hört da einfach nicht auf, damit diese Forderung zu wiederholen.
Wir haben das letztens auch mal mit einer diffusen Intervention versucht und
haben an alle Europaabgeordneten Post zugestellt.
Khaleesi und ich waren da im Europaparlament. Es gibt auch ein lustiges Video, das wir verlinken.
Und wir haben das nochmal so zusammengefasst auf einer Seite mit einer sehr
lustigen Postkarte, die wir auch verlinken, damit man sieht,
dass Breton hier halt wirklich nicht im Interesse der Bevölkerung agiert.
Und deswegen unsere Forderung, bitte nach der Wahl nicht noch mal bestätigt werden soll.
Ich meine, super, ich meine, jetzt haben sie gerade diesen Digital Markets Act
rausgebracht, der quasi so im Geist hat, wir brauchen mehr Markt-
Ja, weil große Monopole sind ein Problem und zu viel Macht konsolidiert sich
auf wenigen und da wo wir das erkennen, da müssen wir jetzt so stark rein regulieren,
damit möglichst viele daran teilnehmen können.
Und dann tut man jetzt hier eigentlich genau das Gegenteil?
Macht ja keinen Sinn. Vor allem würde es ja dann bedeuten, dass die Preise dann
für alle steigen, weil dann muss dann mehr sozusagen an die Telekoms bezahlt werden,
also wer auch immer dann sozusagen davon letztlich profitiert,
das würde ja dann nicht nur die Deutsche Telekom sein.
Aber in dem Moment, wo man eben weniger kleinere Provider hat,
bedeutet das ja dann, dass sie dann eigentlich noch mehr Geld nehmen können.
Also es läuft im Prinzip genau in die Gegenrichtung, als die,
für die eigentlich die EU in den letzten Jahren Partei ergriffen hat.
Ja, und der große Unterschied ist an der Stelle einfach, dass es so gut wie
keine europäischen Big Tech Konzerne gibt,
aber die ISBs sich hier wirklich noch, also gerade eben die großen wie die Deutsche
Telekom, Vodafone, Telefonica, halt damit brüsten, dass sie ja die europäischen
Champions sind und die müssen wir schützen.
Ja, denen ihr Monopol müssen wir erhalten und das Monopol oder Oligopol der
Amerikaner, das müssen wir brechen.
In Wirklichkeit agieren wir da genauso doppelzündig wie die Amis mit ihrem TikTok-Verbot.
Muss man ehrlich sagen. Diese Debatte rund um Netzgebühren und das Leitungsschutzrecht,
die ist leider inzwischen auch weltweit.
Also wir haben inzwischen Konsultationen in Indien, in Brasilien,
in anderen lateinamerikanischen Staaten wird das als Forderung gewälzt und da
ist so ein bisschen der Geist aus der Flasche. Es ist immer ganz wichtig,
da auch nach Südkorea zu schauen.
In Korea gibt es ja sowas schon mit desaströsen Konsequenzen.
Die haben 100 Prozent Fiber to the Home und gleichzeitig steigt die Latenz die
ganze Zeit und die Dienstequalität wird immer schlechter, weil halt die Daten
jetzt alle nur noch irgendwie in Tokio am Internet Exchange dort übergeben werden,
weil keiner mehr in Korea peeren will oder sich zusammenschalten will mit den dortigen ISPs.
Weil zu den Preisen zeigen die alle den Mittelfinger.
Das heißt, könnte auch sein, dass keiner mehr mit der Telekom pieren will und
das dann sozusagen alles im Ausland gemacht werden muss.
Verlierst halt 40 Prozent vom deutschen Markt. Das können sich wenige Unternehmen leisten.
Und zuletzt nochmal, um die Net Neutrality News abzurunden, in den USA stehen
wir auch gerade vor einer großen Entscheidung, weil dort die FCC ja wieder mal
einen Anlauf macht, Netzneutralität wieder einzuführen, nachdem Trump es zuletzt ja 2017 gekillt hat.
Und die neuen Regeln, ich weiß noch, dass der Spezialdienste ein großes Thema
ist, weil da habe ich ein paar Gespräche geführt und die sind nicht so gut,
wie sie schon mal waren unter Obama,
aber ist auf jeden Fall ein guter Schritt, wenn es da wieder irgendwas gibt auf Bundesebene.
Im Moment gibt es da nämlich noch gar nichts, außer in Kalifornien.
So, genug Netzneutralität.
Alright, aber wir haben ja noch ein paar andere Dauerbrenner,
zum Beispiel die immer noch nicht
final abgestimmte Entscheidung zum Thema Chatkontrolle auf EU-Regelung.
Da war ja der letzte Stand eigentlich der, dass es so ganz gut aussieht,
dass das nicht kommt, aber das kippt jetzt schon wieder.
Ja, über dieses Thema müssen wir reden, auch wenn das keiner mehr will,
weil wir ja gerade unter belgischer Ratspräsidentschaft wird heftigst weiter verhandelt.
Wo stehen wir in diesem Prozess?
Tim, du hast vorher gerade eh schon erwähnt, es gibt so diese drei Gesetzgeber auf EU-Ebene.
Die Kommission, die beginnt mit einem Gesetz, das Parlament muss sich dazu verhalten
und die Mitgliedstaaten im Rat der EU müssen sich dazu verhalten.
Wir sind zwei Drittel fertig. Wir haben einen Gesetzesvorschlag,
das Parlament hat sich schon mit seiner Version des Gesetzes dazu geäußert und
nun sind die Mitgliedstaaten dran.
Die haben es in den vergangenen Monaten nicht geschafft, sich zu einigen.
Weil es da eine Sperrminorität gibt, also eine Minderheit an Staaten,
die aber genügend groß sind oder genügend große Anteile an der Bevölkerung Europas haben,
wollten keine Version dieses Gesetzes, sodass es bisher noch keine Einigung gab.
Die Belgier sind in diesem Halbjahr in der Präsidentschaft des Rates zuständig
dafür, so einen Kompromiss zu finden und da arbeiten sie sehr,
sehr, sehr massiv daran. Wir sehen alle paar Wochen einen neuen Text.
Diese Texte werden nicht wirklich besser, aber sie sind halt anders.
Und das ist so eine Zermürbungstaktik. Die ganze Zeit das Thema oben auf der
Agenda halten, die ganze Zeit den Druck aufrechterhalten, hey,
wir müssen uns hier einigen, es geht doch um die Kinder, bitte,
bitte, bitte, macht's doch endlich.
Und diese Taktik der Zermürbung erzeugt gerade eine sehr hohe Gefahr,
dass die Belgier es schaffen,
da einen Kompromiss durchzuboxen und wir noch unter deren Ratspräsidentschaft
eine Einigung im Rat sehen.
Sobald wir so eine Einigung haben, würde der Trilog beginnen.
Also dann würden Parlament, Rat und Kommission sich zusammensetzen,
um ein finales Gesetz auszuverhandeln.
Im Moment ist es so, Österreich hält sowieso stabil. Wir haben das ja parlamentarisch
abgesichert. Die Österreicher können nicht umfallen.
Deutschland ist noch unklar, was Mirka Lisi sagt. Da ist man sozusagen noch
nicht ganz in der Situation im Innenministerium da, wo man sein sollte.
Es ist auch nichts Neues.
Sowieso reichen Deutschland und Österreich alleine ja nicht.
Frankreich hat ja seit Jänner auch einen neuen Premierminister, Gabriela Thal.
Seine Vorgängerin Elisabeth Borne war da um einiges mehr auf unserer Seite,
was Chatkontrolle betrifft. Also auch Frankreich wackelt.
Ja, prinzipiell, es kann sehr schnell gehen, dass wir jetzt einen Kompromiss
sehen, der durchgeht und dann auch der Trilog würde natürlich versucht werden,
noch unter den Belgiern möglichst schnell abgeschlossen zu werden,
weil in der zweiten Jahreshälfte 2024 hat die ungarische Regierung die Vatspräsidentschaft.
Und es weiß noch keiner so genau, was das eigentlich heißt.
Ungarn, Europa, schwierig.
Ungarn und Überwachungsgesetze, unklar. Ja, die sind kein Freund der Freiheit,
aber waren jetzt auch nicht super auf der Überwacherseite bisher.
Ja, also wir haben aber auch nochmal zu bedenken, dass natürlich Europawahlen sind.
Genau und zwar im Juni. Also dann ist ja eigentlich ganz gut,
kann man das so sagen, dass Ungarn genau dann die Ratspräsidentschaft hat,
wenn eigentlich ja so die letzte Legislatur weitgehend dann abgearbeitet sein
sollte und im Prinzip dann ja erstmal wieder neue Dinge auf die Agenda kommen.
Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall auch etwas, dass uns, dass das bewusst so gelegt
wurde, damit da nichts wirklich anbrennen kann direkt nach der Wahl.
Wie, das wurde bewusst so gelegt? Das wird doch nicht gelegt? Wieso?
Also natürlich, du kannst da immer, dann fällt halt jemand aus oder du schiebst
jemanden ein, natürlich wird das geschoben.
Und auch schon viele Jahre im Vorhinein und normalerweise ist es so.
Du meinst jetzt das Gesetz oder die Ratspräsidentschaft?
Die Ratspräsidentschaft, die Ratspräsidentschaft.
Ja, aber wer legt denn das fest, wann die ist? Ist das nicht Round Robin?
Also es kommen schon alle nach der Reihe wieder mal dran, aber die genaue Reihenfolge,
da kannst du schon Dinge drehen.
Zum Beispiel ist es eigentlich vorgesehen, dass wenn du jetzt Wahlen hast,
solltest du nicht die Ratspräsidentschaft haben.
Das ist bisher eigentlich immer so ein Prinzip gewesen, an das sich alle gehalten haben.
Wir haben jetzt aber in Spanien und in Frankreich gesehen, dass man mit dem Prinzip gebrochen hat.
Und normalerweise sollte eigentlich die Ratspräsidentschaft dann sein,
wenn eine stabile Regierung die Geschäfte führt und deswegen auch,
das ist eine diplomatische Aufgabe, diese Ratspräsidentschaft,
die aber viele Fachministerien auch nochmal bindet.
Sprich, du willst da put your best foot forward.
Du willst sozusagen alle deinen Shit at home sortiert haben,
sodass du dich der europäischen Bühne präsentieren kannst.
Und deswegen, man kann da durchaus so ein bisschen was schieben.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, nach Ungarn wäre eigentlich Polen dran oder ist
jetzt auch Polen dran, dann im ersten Halbjahr 2025.
Da hatte man auch große Sorgen, sozusagen zuerst Ungarn, dann Polen unter einer PiS-Regierung.
Wäre ja nicht sonderlich gut für Europa, dass da was weitergeht.
Aber jetzt mit dem Regierungswechsel in Polen sind diese Sorgen der proeuropäischen
PolitikerInnen sicherlich mal ein bisschen hintangestellt.
Aber soviel zur Ratspräsidentschaft. Kommen wir zurück zur Chatkontrolle.
Also ich habe gerade mal nachgeschlagen, also es ist schon ein festgelegtes
Verfahren, das zwar vom Rat der Europäischen Union, da haben wir ihn wieder,
geändert werden kann, aber im Prinzip einem festen Modus folgt.
Ich habe bloß noch nicht gefunden, wo dieser Modus eigentlich genau das letzte Mal festgelegt wurde.
Aber ich kann mir jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass das jetzt so geplant war,
dass Ungarn, also dass das für irgendjemand kurzfristig dahingeschoben wurde,
sondern dass das eigentlich eher Zufall ist.
Ja, also ich habe hier gerade, es gibt so schöne Infoposts vom Europaparlament
und neben mir hängt gerade so alle Ratspräsidentschaften bis 2037.
Das ist schon sehr weit im Vorfeld festgelegt und normalerweise ändert sich daran auch nichts.
Aber ich weiß es eben aus Diskussionen, die es in der Vergangenheit gab,
dass man durchaus da, ich sage mal zumindest mit einer Einigkeit unter den Mitgliedstaaten,
wirst du das schon ändern können.
Ob es da auch mit einer qualifizierten Mehrheit möglich sein kann,
diese Reihenfolge zu ändern, weiß ich nicht.
Nee, es muss einstimmig sein. Einstimmig muss der Turnus akzeptiert werden.
Okay. Ja, also wenn jetzt jemand sagt, hey Leute, wir brauchen eine Wahl bei
uns, können wir bitte irgendwie tauschen mit wem anderen, dann wirst du da vielleicht
eine Lösung finden, aber wenn es einstimmig sein muss, dann….
Hat Ungarn zugestimmt?
Ja, ich nehme mal an, dass es ihnen auch recht war, wenn sie jetzt nicht in
die Rolle gesetzt werden, dass sie laut der EU-Gesetze fertig verhandeln müssen,
weil das wollen sie ja nicht.
Auf jeden Fall eine interessante Geschichte.
Europa ist interessant.
Eine Dimension, die wir noch beleuchten müssen ist, für die Chat-Kontrolle wird
sich natürlich durch die Wahl im Europaparlament auch etwas ändern. 6. bis 10.
Juni, 6. bis 9. Juni sind Wahlen in ganz Europa und Patrick Bayer,
der ja an diesem Gesetz sehr massiv mitverhandelt, wird nicht nochmal antreten.
Anja Hirscher wird versuchen, sein Mandat zu gewinnen für die Piratenpartei und ihm nachzufolgen.
Hoffentlich übernimmt sie auch irgendwie dann sein ganzes Team,
weil natürlich hängt das ganz oft an den parlamentarischen Mitarbeiterinnen,
die ja eigentlich die Hosen anhaben und nicht die Abgeordneten,
in ganz vielen Fällen zumindest.
Wobei Patrick sicherlich einer der wenigen war, die sich auch selber da in die
Verhandlungen aktiv eingebracht haben und überhaupt das Gesetz selber gelesen hat.
Aber es bricht uns sozusagen da jetzt auch der stärkste Kritiker dieses Gesetzes weg,
wobei wir ja zum Glück auch Leute aus Deutschland wie Moritz Körner haben und
Timo Wölken, die auch super kritisch bei dem Thema sind.
Und ich hoffe, dass man da einfach im Verhandlungsteam für Stabilität sorgen
kann, sodass die Parlamentsposition hier noch gut vertreten wird im Trilog,
wenn es denn zu einem kommt.
Und eine spannende Entwicklung, auf die ich hinweisen will, weil wir haben ja
glaube ich in einer vorherigen Folge auch darüber geredet, dass die Parlamentsposition
ja irgendwie sogar ganz okay sein könnte,
weil die so viel besser ist als das, was die Kommission vorgelegt hat.
Dazu gibt es jetzt eine Stellungnahme vom IDPB,
das ist das Gremium der europäischen Datenschutzbehörden, wo alle nationalen
oder in Deutschland Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten zusammenkommen,
um ihre Meinung zu treffen.
Die haben auch eine wichtige, gewichtige Stimme in diesem ganzen Prozess und
die haben zu dieser Position vom Europaparlament gesagt, nee,
sorry, immer noch nicht genügend.
Also das reicht nicht, das ist immer noch mit dem Grundrecht auf Datenschutz nicht vereinbar.
Ja gut, ihr habt Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung abgesichert, aber das ist immer
noch Massenüberwachung, diese Detection Orders gehen viel zu weit,
es ist immer noch das Filtern von unbekannten Child Sexual Abuse Content Teil
von dem Gesetz, was zu großen Fehlerraten führen würde, die die Meinungsfreiheit gefährden.
Also was das bedeutet ist, dass die beste Version der Chat-Kontrolle,
die überhaupt am Tisch liegt, laut Datenschutzbehörden immer noch viel zu schlecht
ist, um mit unseren Grundrechten vereinbart zu sein.
Und wenn man jetzt weiß, dass im Trilog nur das rauskommt, was so das geometrische
Mittel ist zwischen allen Positionen, die schon vorgelegt wurden,
weiß man heute schon, dass das, was da rauskommt, nicht gut genug sein kann.
Ich muss jetzt nochmal doof fragen, ist die Chat-Kontrolle, die jetzt beschlossen
werden soll, ein eigenständiges Gesetz oder ist das nochmal in etwas anderes eingebettet?
Ist ein eigenständiges Gesetz eine Verordnung, die direkt anwendbar wäre in
allen EU-Mitgliedsstaaten?
Okay, das heißt, es könnte als solches scheitern und dann wäre es halt einfach nicht da.
Es gibt jetzt nicht noch irgendwelche anderen Sachen, die da mit drin sind,
die andere Leute jetzt unbedingt haben wollen, sondern es wäre dann am Ende
wirklich eine Entscheidung gegen die Chatkontrolle und nur die Chatkontrolle alleine.
Ja, also es gibt jetzt sozusagen, in dieser Verordnung sind jetzt keine Dinge
drinnen, die man losgelöst von diesem Gesetz so eigentlich haben will.
Wir haben neben der Chat-Kontrolle auch den ganzen Bereich der Altersverifikation
auf Plattformen und auch der Risikoabschätzung von Plattformen aus Jugendschutzsicht.
Das ist aber ein bisschen redundant zum DSA.
Diese Frage der Altersverifikation, die creept auch immer mehr rein in andere
Themenbereiche, zum Beispiel auch im Wahlprogramm der Grünen auf EU-Ebene zum
Beispiel ist auf einmal, yeah, Altersverifikation, super toll.
Das ist sowieso ein Problem an sich.
Die einzige Verbindung, nach der du gerade fragst, die ich sehe,
die da immer wieder politisch genannt wird, ist die sogenannte Interim Derogation.
Über die hat Linus zuletzt auch geredet.
Die Chatkontrolle macht ja etwas verpflichtend, das es eigentlich nicht geben dürfte.
Private Kommunikation sollte nicht gescannt werden dürfen.
Da gibt es ja das Briefgeheimnis, das Grundrecht der Vertraulichkeit der Kommunikation.
Und die E-Privacy-Richtlinie gemeinsam mit der DSGVO verbietet das eigentlich.
Nun hat man schon vor einiger Zeit eine Interim Derogation, also eine zwischenzeitliche
Abweichung von dieser E-Privacy-Richtlinie verabschiedet, damit dieses Scannen
möglich bleibt für die Provider.
Zum Beispiel Facebook scannt alle Nachrichten bei Facebook Messenger,
weil der ist ja unverschlüsselt und da kommt ein allergroßer Teil von allen
angeblichen Kinesis-Missbrauchsdarstellungen auch her, weil Facebook hier freiwillig
alles scannt und das dann meldet an die amerikanische Meldestelle.
Und das wäre nicht möglich ohne dieser Interim Derogation, die ist zuletzt aber
verlängert worden. Bis glaube ich 2025 oder 26, das weiß ich gerade nicht genau.
Aber wir können die Uhr danach stellen, spätestens wenn diese Kannbestimmung ausläuft,
wird die Gegenseite, werden die Innenministerien und die Überwachungspolitikerinnen
wieder sehr laut schreien, dass man die Kinder schützen muss und deswegen diese
Mussbestimmung sofort her muss,
weil ansonsten kann man ja die Kinder nicht mehr schützen mit Massenüberwachung.
Naja gut, also bleibt spannend, hier bis zur letzten Minute der belgischen Ratspräsidentschaft,
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ja, also es gibt einen neuen Text, den verlinken wir auch.
Wir verlinken auch die Analyse von Netzpolitik.org zum letzten Gesetzestext.
Wer da wirklich einsteigen will, hat hier die volle Ladung von dem,
was die Belgier letzte Woche vorgeschlagen haben. Und wir verlinken auch das richtige Mem.
Also was die Belgier da tun ist nämlich, wie Khaleesi richtig schön mit diesem
Mem zusammenfasst, nichts anderes als das Umsortieren der Stühle auf der Titanic.
Also es ist nichts gelöst worden mit diesen neuen Gesetzestexten,
es ist nur put lipstick on a pig. Ja.
Ja, da gibt es auch Updates zu vermelden. Wir hatten das Thema ja letztes Jahr
schon und zuletzt glaube ich im Februar.
Und es ist hier etwas sehr Positives eigentlich passiert.
Eigentlich hätte man sich nämlich hier einigen sollen. Im Februar war eine Verhandlungsrunde
in New York und das ist nicht passiert. passiert.
Man konnte sich nicht einigen. Und das ist eigentlich sehr gut.
Also worum geht es genau? Bei dieser UN Cybercrime Convention,
Geht es um Computerkriminalität? Da steht zumindest außen drauf.
In Wirklichkeit geht es um alle Arten von Verbrechen, die so in oder um oder
mit einem Computer begangen werden.
Da gibt es so einen Katalog von Straftaten, die es überall auf der Welt geben soll.
Es gibt auch einen Katalog von Überwachungsmaßnahmen, die es überall geben muss.
Und dann dürfen die Länder mit ihren Strafverfolgungsbehörden auch sozusagen
interoperabel gemäß diesem Straftatenkatalog oder gemäß diesen Überwachungsmethoden
Daten miteinander austauschen.
Und das eben auch nicht nur für grenzüberschreitende Fälle, sondern zum Beispiel
auch, bei dir hat jemand gehostet, der bei mir eine Straftat begangen hat und so weiter.
Das ist sehr problematisch aus Datenschutzsicht, aus Sicht der Meinungsfreiheit,
weil das ist halt wirklich ein weltweites Treaty, da sind alle 193 Staaten der Welt mit am Tisch.
Und diese Straftatbestände sind immer noch nicht so gebaut,
dass sie für Ethical Hacker, für SicherheitsforscherInnen, für InvestigativjournalistInnen
oder andere Gruppen, die mit solchen Tools operieren, nicht gefährlich werden können.
Und wie gesagt, wir reden ja auch von China, wir reden von Russland, wir reden von Iran.
Und die Überwachungsbefugnisse sind auch immer noch viel zu weitreichend,
die inkludieren auch noch sowas
wie Echtzeitverkehrsdatenüberwachung und Echtzeitinhaltsdatenüberwachung.
So Bestimmungen, die Staatstrojaner verpflichtend machen würden,
die haben wir zum Glück schon rausbekommen, aber es bleibt genügend Problematisches übrig.
Und ganz wichtig sind halt auch die Sicherheitsschranken, die Menschenrechtsgarantien,
die mit dem Vertrag eigentlich auch kommen müssten, wenn man schon so viel Macht
in die Hände von Strafverfolgungsbehörden legt, die fehlen noch.
Und gerade wenn das interoperabel sein soll, muss man sich ja auf gewisse rechtsstaatliche
Garantien auch an beiden Enden der Leitung verlassen können.
Wie gesagt, man wollte sich da einigen in der letzten Verhandlungsrunde in New
York und das hat man nicht geschafft.
Das war wirklich ein bisschen ein magischer Moment, weil man dachte,
man macht den Sack zu und man legt sich einfach auf eine der Optionen fest und
es gab wirklich koordinierten Widerstand Und vor allem für uns als Zivilgesellschaft
war das extrem spannend,
weil seit anderthalb Jahren oder länger reden wir uns da mundfusselig darüber.
Und zum ersten Mal kamen die Staatenvertreter her und sagten so,
oh really, this is a human rights dimension?
I wasn't aware. Also, wo du dir denkst, was haben wir euch die letzten Jahre alles gesagt?
Und wir hatten ja immer diese dreiminütigen Redepreiträge dort.
Ist wirklich bemerkenswert zu sehen, dass vor allem auch bei den europäischen
Staaten, aber auch bei Lateinamerika, das jetzt soweit angekommen ist,
dass die sagen, nee, wir können dem so nicht zustimmen.
Und auch die EU-Kommission, die hier wirklich bereit war, let's do a deal,
ja, wir geben euch das, ja, Grundrechte sind nicht so wichtig.
Wir können schon Zugeständnisse machen. Und da gab es dann wirklich eine Revolte
von den Mitgliedstaaten, die da einfach gesagt haben, nee,
wir fühlen uns dann durch die EU-Kommission nicht mehr vertreten,
wenn hier zu stark abgewichen wird von dem, was wir uns zum Beispiel auch als
Deutschland an Grundrechten vorstellen würden bei diesem Vertrag.
Kannst du mir mal kurz näher bringen, inwiefern denn die EU-Kommission auf UN-Ebene,
die ja im Prinzip eine Gruppe von unabhängigen Staaten darstellen soll,
da wirkt und vertreten ist?
Das ist eine gute Frage, Tim. Eigentlich haben die gar nichts zu melden dort,
weil, wie du sagst, die sind kein souveräner Staat.
Aber, das hat wahrscheinlich mehr verhandlungstaktische Gründe,
du kannst dich sozusagen als Staatenverbund natürlich auch zusammenschließen
und sagen, diese Person vertritt uns und die spricht jetzt im Namen von dieser Liste an Staaten.
Das gibt es auch nicht nur in der EU, zum Beispiel CARICOM,
die karibischen Staaten tun das auch die ganze Zeit, da sind ja auch sehr viele
kleine Inselstaaten vertreten, die vielleicht sogar an jemanden hinschicken
würden und die sind dann vertreten über eine Person oder ein ganzes Verhandlungsteam,
die für diese ganze Liste an Staaten spricht.
Macht ja auch Sinn in dem Moment, wo man wirklich, wo es klar ist,
okay, wir werden hier als Vereinigung sozusagen durch unsere Repräsentanten
auch nicht nennenswert etwas anderes vertreten, als wir jetzt einzeln vertreten würden.
Ja, und im Ablaufen tut das dann so,
dass bei den Runden, in denen sich die Staaten zu Wort melden über gewisse Teile
des Vertrags, die EU-Kommission als erstes spricht und dann können und tun auch
viele Staaten sich danach nochmal melden, also viele EU-Staaten.
Und die EU-Staaten sagen dann immer, wir schließen uns den Äußerungen der EU-Kommission
an und sagen noch folgende Dinge in unserer nationalen Kapazität.
Das sind dann oft so die Dinge, wo der Mitgliedstaat nochmal Akzente setzen
will oder wo er nochmal gewisse Punkte bestärken will, die die EU-Kommission
vielleicht nicht so stark auf vorne gestrichen hat.
Ganz ehrlich, ich weiß nicht, ob diese Verhandlungstaktik gut ist.
Weil wenn du jetzt 27 EU-Staaten hast, die alle für sich sprechen.
Und stattdessen hast du nur einmal die EU-Kommission und dann kommt aber die Liste mit Pakistan,
Indien, Iran, Russland, die sich extrem oft zu Wort melden, Ägypten,
die wirklich keine Hilfe in den Verhandlungen waren.
Und ich verstehe nicht, ob das so eine kluge Strategie ist und da,
wo es Widersprüche gibt, geht die natürlich gar nicht mehr auf.
Und das ist ein Teil von dem, was jetzt hier auch passiert ist,
wobei natürlich die großen Widersprüche halt einfach nicht aufgelöst werden konnten,
weil einfach die verschiedenen Versionen des Vertrags doch immer sehr weit auseinander sind.
Wo lässt uns das jetzt zurück?
Lässt sich dort dann noch Input geben, um die bisherige Blockade wenigstens
aufrecht zu erhalten, weil der ganze Prozess kippt so ein bisschen.
Die haben eigentlich kein Budget mehr.
Die Madame Chair, die das immer verhandelt hat, eine algerische Diplomatin,
die ist inzwischen in Pension.
Die hat auch bei der letzten Session so Mic Drop gesagt, so,
if we can't agree, you need a new chair. I'm gone.
Und das hat sie auch gemacht.
Du meinst kein Budget, um jetzt noch diese Verhandlungen weiter zu finanzieren,
um irgendwo hinzureisen, sich zu treffen und so weiter.
Korrekt. Und das Sekretariat und so weiter. Also das kostet ja alles Geld.
Und deswegen ist da jetzt dieser ursprüngliche Plan, im Juni bei der Generalversammlung
der UNO dieses Treaty zur Abstimmung zu bringen, zumindest in Zweifel gezogen.
Es kann natürlich passieren, dass die sie im April auf irgendwas einigen.
Es wäre unter Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit.
Das ist oft, wo die Ränkelei dann besonders drastisch wird.
Ähm, ja, aber wir dürfen uns hier in Wien drauf freuen, nochmal Host für eine
ganz wichtige Verhandlungsrunde zu sein und werden unser Bestes geben,
da uns einzusetzen und danach darüber zu berichten.
Meine Kollegin Tanja Facherthaler, die unsere Delegationsleiterin ist,
war auch in dem Podcast Dicke Bretter.
Das ist ja im Chaos Radio Feed dort unter Nummer 286 zu finden.
Da hat sie auch nochmal sehr gut irgendwie dargelegt, wie dieses Thema denn
aktuell gerade so sich auch anfühlt. Ich glaube, sie ist da ja nochmal viel
mehr drinnen, als ich das bin.
Deswegen das nochmal so als Empfehlung und wir werden dann berichten oder man
wird lesen, wie es aufgeht.
Also unsere Haltung ist klar, no treaty is better than a bad treaty. Lieber nicht.
Wenn du jetzt wir sagst, dann meinst du Epicenter Works als Gruppe oder wie
seid ihr da eingeloggt in den Prozess offiziell?
Also wir sind da als Epicenter Works natürlich vertreten, tun das aber in der
Koalition mit ganz vielen anderen NGOs.
Also wir haben da zum Beispiel auch eine NGO, die einen anderen Status bei der
UNO hat und in deren Namen wir sprechen können.
Wir haben aber auch die IFF, Privacy International, Access Now,
der Regios Digitalis und viele andere NGOs, die diesen UNO-Prozess begleiten
und mit uns daran arbeiten.
Da gibt es auch eine enge Abstimmung, was die Positionierungen betrifft und
wie man konkret sich da einbringt.
Und da sind wir sozusagen wirklich in so einer weltweiten Koalition.
Leider sind es eh viel zu wenige europäische NGOs, die sich daran beteiligen.
Sollten wir verlieren und es gibt ein schlechtes Schiti, wird es doch nochmal
spannend, weil das muss durch das Europaparlament bestätigt werden.
Und das wäre dann auch nochmal ein Weg, es für Europa zum Scheitern zu bringen.
Für den Rest der Welt hilft uns das nicht.
Alright. Gut, jetzt hatten wir schon eine ganze Menge schlechte Nachrichten.
Da können wir auch nochmal eine hinterher schieben.
Und zwar geht es hier um eine Entscheidung bezüglich des Informationsfreiheitsgesetz.
Und zwar gab es hier eine Entscheidung des Bundesverwaltungsgerichts.
Das Ganze basiert auf einer Klage des Bundesinnenministeriums gegen den Bundesbeauftragten
für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit.
Also hier wird sozusagen mit harten Bandagen intern gekämpft.
Und es bezieht sich auf das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz dahingehend,
ob denn Informationsanfragen nach diesem Gesetz per E-Mail beantwortet werden müssen oder nicht.
Und nachdem es in der Sache schon mal eine Entscheidung des Oberverwaltungsgerichts
Münster gab, was genau gesagt hat, so ja nö, E-Mail ist schon okay irgendwie,
wir leben ja in modernen Zeiten,
hat jetzt das Bundesverwaltungsgericht anders entschieden und gesagt,
so nö, wir leben ja in Deutschland,
da kann man auch mal per Post antworten.
Also so mit ausgedrucktem Internet sozusagen.
Was ist mit Fax?
Weiß ich nicht, aber der Postweg wurde sozusagen jetzt explizit erlaubt und
das ist natürlich vor allem ein Problem für das Projekt Frag den Staat,
was sich halt hier auch entsprechend aufregt und zu Wort gemeldet hat und das
natürlich total beklagt, Weil wir erinnern uns,
dass halt Frag den Staat natürlich vor allem darauf basiert,
dass es eben hier einen automatisierten elektronischen Ablauf dieser Anfragen
gibt und vor allem steckt dann natürlich dahinter,
dass dann eine Anfrage auch nicht mehr anonym erfolgen kann.
Denn wenn es einen Postweg gibt, dann muss es ja sozusagen auch eine Anschrift
geben und damit muss es dann eben auch eine Person geben und fragt den Staat,
beklagt natürlich dann vor allem diesen Aspekt, dass also hier sozusagen Leute
davon abgeschreckt werden sollen,
überhaupt eine solche Informationsanfrage zu machen. machen.
Und ja, das ist natürlich jetzt wirklich eine problematische Situation und Frag
den Staat hat jetzt angekündigt,
das erstmal dahingehend abzuwarten, bis es auch die detaillierte Urteilsbegründung gibt und wenn.
Die dann vorliegt, dann werden weitere Schritte unternommen.
Und generell steht hier die Forderung natürlich nach einem klar neu formulierten Transparenzgesetz,
was halt mal sicherstellt, dass man auf Bundesebene diesen Zugriff selbstverständlich
elektronisch und anonym machen kann und dass das einfach mal klar geregelt ist.
Aber man sieht einfach, dass hier sich der Staat dann doch noch sehr dagegen
wehrt, befragt zu werden und das ist natürlich wirklich problematisch.
Das ist so letztklassig und so jenseitig.
Ich meine, wir leben in einer Informationsgesellschaft. Ein transparenter Staat ist nichts, das man,
gut dünkenhaft irgendwie noch so, ja, habt ihr ein bisschen was,
das ist die Voraussetzung dafür, dass Demokratie Legitimation hat.
Das ist wirklich nicht verständlich, da jetzt so auf analoge Dinge wieder umzustellen,
um ja bewusst so Projekte wie Frag den Staat abzudrehen.
Also ich meine, wer wird sein Grundrecht auf Informationsfreiheit per Post in Anspruch nehmen?
Also ja, es ist vor allem, was ich immer sehr problematisch finde,
ist so, dass der Staat sich hier auch so ein bisschen aufspielt,
als wäre er so eine eigenständige Entität und der Bürger wäre in gewisser Hinsicht jetzt nur so ein,
Außenseiter und so ein Störfaktor.
Und das ist halt nicht mein Verständnis von Staat, sondern Staat ist ja sozusagen,
den gibt es ja nur, weil die Bürger beschlossen haben, einen zu haben.
Das heißt, der gehört uns ja allen und natürlich muss da eine Beteiligung möglich
sein und vor allem muss es dann eine Transparenz geben,
weil nur durch Transparenz hast du eine Kontrolle, eine wirksame und nur mit
Kontrolle kannst du eben, ja.
Korruption und andere negative Aspekte, die sich zwangsläufig bei solchen Organisationen
mit der Zeit ergeben, wenn du denen nicht auf den Finger schaust, verhindert werden.
Also das ist meiner Meinung nach nicht haltbar und wir werden das natürlich
hier verfolgen, wie das weitergeht, wenn die Urteilsbegründung raus ist und
was fragt den Staat dann unternehmen wird, bin mir eigentlich relativ sicher,
dass hier auch eine sehr kreative Antwort kommt.
Ja, davon ist bei Arne auszugehen, Mit dem wird auch nicht langweilig.
Nee.
Gut. Gut. Das war's für heute.
Erstmal, denke ich mal, haben wir trotzdem unsere zwei Stunden hier voll bekommen.
Ja, irgendwie wird's nicht weniger.
Ja, jetzt geh auf deinen Joint in die Innenstadt.
Ich hab noch Zeit. Ist ja noch früh. Ist ja erst ab 20 Uhr.
Genieß es. ist.
Aber klar doch. Gut. Ich sage vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Danke Thomas.
Und wir hören uns dann nächste Woche wieder. Bis bald. Tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.